Thank you for listening to The Rest Is History. For weekly bonus episodes, ad-free listening, early access to series, and membership of our much-loved chat community, go to therestishistory.com and join the club. That is therestishistory.com. Sitting Bull, most renowned Sioux of modern history, is dead. He was an Indian with a white man's spirit of hatred and revenge for those who had wronged him and his. In his day, he saw his son and his tribe gradually driven from their possessions, forced to give up their old hunting grounds and espouse the hard-working and uncongenial avocations of the whites. And these his conquerors were marked in their dealings with his people by selfishness, falsehood, and treachery. What wonder that his wild nature, untamed by years of subjection, should still revolt! What wonder that a fiery rage still
感谢收听《历史的余味》。如需每周额外剧集、无广告收听、抢先观看系列节目以及加入我们备受喜爱的聊天社区，请前往 therestishistory.com 加入俱乐部。网址是 therestishistory.com。现代史上最著名的苏族人“坐牛”死了。他是一个印第安人，却怀着白人那种对伤害过他和他的族人的人的仇恨与报复心理。在他那个时代，他眼睁睁看着他的儿子和他的部落逐渐被赶出家园，被迫放弃旧日的狩猎场，去从事白人那种艰苦且不合心意的工作。而这些征服者在对待他的族人时，表现出的全是自私、虚伪和背信弃义。难怪他那未被多年屈从所驯服的野性依然会反抗！难怪那炽热的愤怒依然
burned within his breast, and that he should seek every opportunity of obtaining vengeance upon his natural enemies. The proud spirit of the original owners of these vast prairies, inherited through centuries of fierce and bloody wars for their possession, lingered last in the bosom of Sitting Bull. With his fall, the nobility of the Redskin is extinguished, and what few are left are a pack of whining curs who lick the hand that smites them. The whites, by law of conquest, by justice of civilization, are masters of the American continent, and the best safety of the frontier settlements will be secured by the total annihilation of the few remaining Indians. Why not annihilation? Their glory has fled, their spirit broken, their manhood effaced. Better that they die than live the miserable wretches that they are. History would forget these latter despicable beings and speak in
在他胸中燃烧，难怪他会寻求一切机会向他的天敌复仇。这些广袤草原原始主人那高傲的精神，通过几个世纪为保卫领地而进行的残酷血腥战争传承下来，最后留存在了“坐牛”的胸膛里。随着他的倒下，红种人的高贵也随之熄灭，剩下的那几个不过是一群只会摇尾乞怜、舔舐打手之手的懦夫。白人凭借征服法则和文明的正义，成为了美洲大陆的主人，而边境定居点的最大安全将通过彻底消灭仅存的印第安人来保障。为什么不消灭他们呢？他们的荣耀已逝，精神已碎，男子气概已荡然无存。与其像现在这样苟延残喘，不如让他们死去。历史会遗忘这些卑微的残存者，而在
later ages of the glory of these grand kings of forest and plain. So that, a jaw-dropping editorial in the Saturday Pioneer, published in Aberdeen in South Dakota on the 20th of December 1890, was by L. Frank Baum, who was, of course, the author of The Wizard of Oz. And Dominic, people often say, well, that escalated quickly. And you begin reading it and it seems a moving threnody on the death of Sitting Bull, a tribute to the nobility and character of the Sioux. And then it ends up with him saying, well, let's kill them all. I know, it's extraordinary, isn't it? Sitting Bull has died. What a great man he was. The rest are whining curs that lick the hand that feeds
后世传颂那些森林与平原伟大君王的荣耀。所以，1890年12月20日发表在南达科他州阿伯丁《星期六先驱报》上那篇令人瞠目结舌的社论，作者正是L·弗兰克·鲍姆，当然，他也是《绿野仙踪》的作者。多米尼克，人们常说，哇，事态升级得真快。你开始读它时，它似乎是一首关于“坐牛”之死的感人挽歌，是对苏族人高贵品质的致敬。然后结尾却变成了他说，好吧，让我们把他们全杀光。我知道，这太不可思议了，不是吗？“坐牛”死了。他曾是多么伟大的人啊。剩下的人都是些舔舐喂养者之手的摇尾乞怜的狗
them or something. So let's get rid of the lot. Unbelievable. Yeah. And I was looking up some more of his editorials. I mean, you yourself, you've been known to write the occasional right-wing editorial in a newspaper. Trenchant, I think is the word, Tom. Trenchant. Yes. But I mean, nothing on this scale. So when he's not calling for basically the genocide of the Sioux, he's describing General Miles, the man who effectively destroyed the last resistance of the Lakota war bands. He's describing him as weak and vacillating. And it just seems amazing. It's incredible, isn't it? The great thing about that editorial, though, is that it's already published in the short period of time between the death of Sitting Bull and the Wounded Knee Massacre, which are the two great subjects that we'll be talking about in this final episode. The great thing about that editorial, horrible as it is, is it absolutely
之类的。所以让我们把他们全处理掉吧。难以置信。是的。我查了一些他写的其他社论。我是说，你自己也曾因在报纸上写过偶尔的右翼社论而闻名。汤姆，我想那个词应该是“尖锐”。尖锐。是的。但我的意思是，没有达到这种程度。所以，当他没有在呼吁对苏族人进行种族灭绝时，他正在描述迈尔斯将军，那个实际上摧毁了拉科塔战争部落最后抵抗的人。他形容他软弱且动摇。这看起来太令人震惊了。这太不可思议了，不是吗？不过，那篇社论最了不起的地方在于，它发表在“坐牛”之死和伤膝河大屠杀之间的短暂时期内，而这两者正是我们在本期最后一集中要讨论的两个重大主题。那篇社论最了不起的地方，尽管它很可怕，在于它绝对
captures that strange ambiguity of American attitudes to the Plains Indians. Because on the one hand, there's all that stuff about, oh, their great nobility, these grand kings of forest and plain, the wild nature untamed by years of subjection. And then on the other hand, the whites by laws of conquest, by justice of civilization, are masters of the American continent. There is that kind of social Darwinist and the lack of magnanimity in it, actually. No sense of guilt, no sense of conscience or regret. I mean, maybe this is overstretching it, but one of the famous characters in The Wizard of Oz is the cowardly lion.
捕捉到了美国人对平原印第安人那种奇怪的矛盾态度。因为一方面，有所有关于“哦，他们的高贵，这些森林与平原的伟大君王，未被多年屈从所驯服的野性”的言论。而另一方面，白人凭借征服法则和文明的正义，成为了美洲大陆的主人。这其中有一种社会达尔文主义，而且实际上缺乏宽宏大量。没有负罪感，没有良知或悔恨。我是说，也许这有点牵强，但《绿野仙踪》里的著名角色之一是胆小狮。
The lion that has been broken and tamed and is too scared to be fierce and wild in the way that a lion should. Maybe I'm over-egging it. But, I mean, it does set quite a light on The Wizard of Oz. It does indeed, yeah. Anyway, so he went there. Again, I didn't know anything about this but looked it up he arrived there in 1887 um in south dakota and started up as a shopkeeper and then he took over
那只被折断了傲骨、被驯服，因为太害怕而无法展现狮子应有的凶猛与野性的狮子。也许我有点过度解读了。但是，这确实为《绿野仙踪》投下了一道光。确实如此，是的。总之，他去了那里。同样，我对此一无所知，但查了一下，他于1887年到达南达科他州，起初是一名店主，然后他接手了
as editor of the saturday pioneer in 1890 so the same year that he's writing that editorial so he's he's going in hard isn't he yeah very hard so it's interesting you said he moved to south dakota because obviously in the last episode we talked about how many people did. The pressure from the Republican administration to admit South Dakota and North Dakota as two states that they're hoping are going to be Republican and hold the balance of power in Congress. The enormous pressure on the reservations from the advance of the railroad, the death of the bison, the arrival of so many settlers. And then that, we talked, didn't we, about the ghost dance movement, this sort of extraordinary cult millenarian movement that really has gathered strength in the summer of 1890 because of the drought and because Native American society is in such freefall. And the press feeding frenzy and the arrival of the troops
1890年《星期六先驱报》的编辑工作，也就是他写那篇社论的同一年，所以他下手很重，不是吗？是的，非常重。所以很有趣，你说他搬到了南达科他州，因为显然在上一集中我们谈到了有多少人这样做。共和党政府施加压力，要求接纳南达科他州和北达科他州为两个州，他们希望这两个州能成为共和党的地盘，并在国会中保持权力平衡。铁路的推进、野牛的灭绝、大量定居者的到来，给保留地带来了巨大的压力。然后，我们谈到了“鬼舞”运动，这种非凡的邪教千禧年运动，由于干旱和美洲原住民社会陷入如此严重的衰退，在1890年夏天真正积聚了力量。媒体的疯狂炒作和军队的到来
that General Miles has sent all these troops mobilized a huge component of the US Army. And then we ended last time by the press point the finger quite unfairly at Sitting Bull. So he's the ringleader in all this and there's going to be a massive bloody uprising. And remember Buffalo Bill said,
迈尔斯将军调动了所有这些部队，动员了美国陆军的一个庞大组成部分。然后我们上次结束时，媒体非常不公平地将矛头指向了“坐牛”。所以他是这一切的幕后主使，将会有一场大规模的血腥起义。还记得布法罗·比尔说，
I'll go and get him. I know Sitting Bull. I've worked with Sitting Bull. And then Agent McLaughlin, who hates Sitting Bull with a passion, says, I'll go and get Sitting Bull. Leave it with me. Yeah, I'll do it. And so Sitting Bull doesn't even know all this is happening. You know, that all these sort of forces are gathering against him.
“我去把他抓来。我认识‘坐牛’。我和‘坐牛’共事过。”然后麦克劳林探员，他极其痛恨“坐牛”，说：“我去把‘坐牛’抓来。交给我吧。是的，我会搞定的。”所以“坐牛”甚至不知道这一切正在发生。你知道，所有这些力量都在集结针对他。
That the storm clouds of... Public obloquy. Yeah. Yeah. A gathering. A new storm. Exactly. But he is oblivious to this, Tom. Because he's in love, isn't he? Ish. He's been hanging around with Mrs. A gathering. A new storm. Exactly. But he is oblivious to this, Tom.
那风暴云……公众的谴责。是的。是的。正在聚集。一场新的风暴。没错。但他对此一无所知，汤姆。因为他恋爱了，不是吗？算是吧。他一直和韦尔登夫人混在一起。一场新的风暴。没错。但他对此一无所知，汤姆。
Because he's in love, isn't he? Ish. He's been hanging around with Mrs. Weldon. Mrs. Weldon is a new arrival on the scene. We always like to throw in a few new characters near the end of a series to spice things up. She's from Switzerland and she's in her early 50s. And she, in a way that we've already alluded to, but obviously would become very familiar later on, she has basically fallen in love with Native American culture, with the idea of Native Americans. Yeah, because you don't get, I mean, kind of less Lakota war chief than a 50-year-old Swiss.
因为他恋爱了，不是吗？算是吧。他一直和韦尔登夫人混在一起。韦尔登夫人是新出现的人物。我们总是喜欢在系列剧快结束时加入几个新角色来增加趣味。她来自瑞士，50岁出头。正如我们已经提到的，但显然后来会变得非常熟悉，她基本上已经爱上了美洲原住民文化，爱上了美洲原住民的概念。是的，因为你找不到，我是说，比一个50岁的瑞士人更不像拉科塔战争首领的人了。
No, you don't. Not at all. No offence to Swiss listeners. But that's the appeal, isn't it? That's the appeal for Mrs. Weldon. Yeah. Is that, you know, the cuckoo clock or whatever, chocolate, melted cheese. She's sick of them. She's had enough. She wants the sun dance. Right, exactly. So she's gone over to the US and she's joined an Indian rights group.
不，你找不到。一点也不。无意冒犯瑞士听众。但这就是吸引力，不是吗？这就是韦尔登夫人的吸引力。是的。就是，你知道，布谷鸟钟什么的，巧克力，融化的奶酪。她厌倦了这些。她受够了。她想要太阳舞。没错，正是这样。所以她去了美国，加入了一个印第安人权利组织。
So there's an element of a much older and more Swiss Greta Thunberg. Yeah. She's gone over to the US. Has she started dressing up as a Lakota though? I don't know that she wears Lakota dress, but I do know that she's moved to the reservation. So having initially sort of corresponded and done public pressure and stuff, she decides, you know what, I'm actually just going to go and live at Standing Rock. And she goes to the Standing Rock agency and she writes to agent McLaughlin and says, I love Sitting Bull. He's
所以这其中有一种更古老、更瑞士版的格蕾塔·通贝里的成分。是的。她去了美国。不过她开始打扮成拉科塔人了吗？我不知道她是否穿拉科塔服装，但我确实知道她搬到了保留地。所以，在最初进行了一些通信和公众压力等活动后，她决定，你知道吗，我实际上要搬到立岩去住。她去了立岩代理处，写信给麦克劳林探员说，我爱“坐牛”。他
brilliant. I think of him like a father. And she moves in with him. So he's built these two cabins on the banks of the Grand River with his sort of coterie, his kind of following. So his extended family and friends and stuff. And Mrs. Weldon arrives with her son, Christy, who's 12. I don't know anything about Christy. I mean, God knows what he makes of all this. Are they Protestants? Must be. I would have thought if they're Swiss. Because McLaughlin is a Christie. I mean, God knows what he makes of all this. Are they Protestants?
很棒。我把他当作父亲一样。然后她搬去和他住在一起。所以他在大河岸边用他的小圈子，也就是他的追随者，建造了这两间小屋。所以他的大家庭和朋友之类的。韦尔登夫人带着她12岁的儿子克里斯蒂来了。我对克里斯蒂一无所知。我是说，天知道他怎么看待这一切。他们是新教徒吗？一定是。如果他们是瑞士人的话，我本来会这么想。因为麦克劳林是一个……天知道他怎么看待这一切。他们是新教徒吗？
Must be. I would have thought if they're Swiss. Because McLaughlin is a very devout Catholic, isn't he? Yes, he is. So the idea that Sitting Bull is now hanging out with Swiss Protestants, I mean, just confirms his darkest suspicions. You reckon? Well, I think it must be playing into his animus against Sitting Bull. He's like Charles V in the middle of the 16th century, is he?
一定是。如果他们是瑞士人的话，我本来会这么想。因为麦克劳林是一个非常虔诚的天主教徒，不是吗？是的，他是。所以“坐牛”现在和瑞士新教徒混在一起的想法，我是说，这证实了他最黑暗的怀疑。你觉得呢？嗯，我想这一定是在加剧他对“坐牛”的敌意。他就像16世纪中叶的查理五世，是吗？
But the weird thing is, is that actually Sitting Bull is not really, I mean, he doesn't experience the ghost dance, does he? Because the great thing about him was that he could see into the future. He is afforded visions, but it doesn't work for him. No, not at all. He's probably distracted by fondues and stuff. So Mrs. Weldon has moved in. He hears about the ghost dance and he says,
但奇怪的是，“坐牛”实际上并没有，我是说，他并没有经历“鬼舞”，对吧？因为他最了不起的地方在于他能预见未来。他被赋予了异象，但这对他不起作用。不，一点也不。他可能被奶酪火锅之类的东西分心了。所以韦尔登夫人搬进来了。他听说了“鬼舞”，他说，
I'm interested in it because he's interested in spiritual things so he gets this guy kicking bear he says come over to my sort of bit of the reservation and teach us the dance and they held the dance and they have more dances sitting bull presides over them and when dancers have visions, he says, you know, what did you see? And he tries to interpret what it means. But he doesn't have any visions himself. This is the tragic thing. So he tries to have ghost dance visions, but he doesn't succeed. I mean, Sitting Bull is renowned for the truth of his visions.
“我对它很感兴趣”，因为他对精神层面的事物感兴趣，所以他找来了这个叫“踢熊”的家伙，他说：“到我这片保留地来，教我们跳舞。”他们举行了舞蹈，他们跳了更多的舞，“坐牛”主持了这些舞蹈，当舞者们出现异象时，他说：“你知道，你看到了什么？”他试图解读这意味着什么。但他自己没有任何异象。这就是悲剧所在。所以他试图获得“鬼舞”的异象，但他没有成功。我是说，“坐牛”以其异象的真实性而闻名。
I wonder if any of the ghost dancers have second thoughts. If Sitting Bull isn't seeing what is the visions of the future that others are claiming to see do you think they think maybe they're bogus don't know maybe they just think he's a busted flush i mean this hangs over him because in particular his authority partly because of the agent openly humiliating him his authority on the reservation is in deep decline and actually he's lost a lot of his authority to Gaul. Yeah. Tom, the fashion of, you know, the captain of the team and stuff, hasn't he?
我想知道是否有任何“鬼舞”舞者会产生怀疑。如果“坐牛”没有看到其他人声称看到的未来异象，你认为他们会觉得这些可能是假的吗？不知道，也许他们只是觉得他已经过气了。我是说，这对他来说是个阴影，特别是他的权威，部分原因是探员公开羞辱他，他在保留地上的权威正在严重衰落，实际上他已经失去了很多对高尔的权威。是的。汤姆，球队队长之类的风尚，不是吗？
Much admired by Mrs. Custer. Yes. So Gaul has now said, let's collaborate with these guys. Let's get on with the reservation bosses. And Sitting Bull has none of it. And some historians have suggested Sitting Bull embraces the ghost dance, not because he massively believes in it, but because it's a really good way to restore his authority
深受卡斯特夫人的钦佩。是的。所以高尔现在说，让我们和这些人合作吧。让我们和保留地的老板们搞好关系。而“坐牛”对此完全不屑一顾。一些历史学家认为，“坐牛”拥抱“鬼舞”，不是因为他非常相信它，而是因为这是恢复他权威的一个非常好的方式
against the more, inverted commas, progressive chiefs. Because Gaul is now kind of wearing Western clothes, isn't he? And kind of dabbling with Christianity. Yeah. So Mrs. Weldon, she, as you would expect, if she is indeed a Swiss Calvinist. She thinks this is madness. She says to Sitting Bull, don't get into this ghost dance business. If you do, they will turn against you.
去对抗那些，加引号的，进步派首领。因为高尔现在有点穿西式服装了，不是吗？而且还在接触基督教。是的。所以韦尔登夫人，她，正如你所料，如果她确实是一个瑞士加尔文教徒的话。她认为这简直是疯了。她对“坐牛”说，不要卷入这个“鬼舞”生意。如果你这样做，他们会反过来对付你。
People will use it as a pretext to kill you. And actually, Sitting Bull says to her, well, I'd be very happy if they did kill me, frankly. I'm really miserable. I'm tired. I've got nothing to do. He says his heart would find rest if the soldiers did kill him and mrs weldon then has a massive strop and says right that's it i'm out of here i'm gone and so she disappears she takes christy and off they go and um lots of observers said when she
人们会把它当作杀你的借口。实际上，“坐牛”对她说，好吧，坦白说，如果他们真的杀了我，我会很高兴的。我真的很痛苦。我累了。我无事可做。他说如果士兵们真的杀了他，他的心就能得到安息。然后韦尔登夫人大发雷霆，说：“好吧，就这样，我走了，我离开了。”所以她消失了，她带着克里斯蒂走了，他们离开了。嗯，许多观察家说，当她
left it was like the light went out of sitting bull's life like the presence of this swiss widow was what was keeping him going. And now he's really depressed and miserable. Fondue's gone. No more fondues. The high precision time pieces have gone. There's nothing left to live for. Yes, exactly. The elaborate and frankly
离开时，就像“坐牛”生命中的光熄灭了一样，就像这位瑞士寡妇的存在一直在支撑着他。现在他真的很沮丧和痛苦。奶酪火锅没了。再也没有奶酪火锅了。高精度的计时器也没了。没什么可活的了。是的，正是如此。他所寄予希望的那些精心策划且坦率地说
slightly shady banking arrangements that he had, which he'd pinned his hopes, have vanished. The tragedy of it, even racist, genocidal columnists can sense the tragedy of it. They can indeed. The only person who doesn't, of course, is Agent McLaughlin. Agent McLaughlin is, while this is going on,
稍微有点阴暗的银行安排，已经烟消云散了。这其中的悲剧，即使是种族主义、种族灭绝的专栏作家也能感受到其中的悲剧。他们确实能。当然，唯一没有感受到的人是麦克劳林探员。麦克劳林探员在这一切发生时，
is sort of sharpening his knives. He thinks the Mrs. Weldon stuff, by the way, is an absolute disgrace. And he says, there's no doubt in my mind that she and Sitting Bull are sleeping together, which seems not to have been true. But McLaughlin says he's a polygamous libertine and habitual liar, a man of low cunning, devoid of a single manly principle in his nature or honourable trait of character, capable of inciting others to any amount of mischief. And that's what he's worried about, isn't it? That he will cause trouble. Exactly. So there are different versions of exactly what happens next, but I think what
正在磨刀霍霍。顺便说一句，他认为韦尔登夫人的事情简直是耻辱。他说：“我毫不怀疑她和‘坐牛’在睡觉”，这似乎并非事实。但麦克劳林说他是一个“一夫多妻的放荡者和惯犯，一个卑鄙狡诈的人，天性中没有任何男子气概或高尚的品格，有能力煽动他人进行任何程度的恶作剧。”这就是他所担心的，不是吗？他会惹麻烦。正是如此。所以关于接下来到底发生了什么有不同的版本，但我认为
follows seems pretty fair, pretty reasonable. So that McLaughlin's solution to the Sitting Bull issue, which I mean, isn't really an issue, but he's trumped it up, is he will use the agency police. Who are Lakota themselves. Who are Lakota themselves, exactly. They're called the Metal Breasts, the Cheska Mazza. I don't know how to pronounce that. We'll just call them the Metal Breasts, I guess, because they wear their badges, kind of big sheriff-type badges. They're going to arrest Sitting Bull on the 20th of December, which is the day when everyone gets their rations,
接下来的事情似乎相当公平，相当合理。所以麦克劳林解决“坐牛”问题的方案，我是说，这并不是什么真正的问题，但他捏造了它，就是他将使用保留地警察。他们本身就是拉科塔人。他们本身就是拉科塔人，正是如此。他们被称为“金属胸甲”，切斯卡·马扎。我不知道怎么发音。我们姑且叫他们“金属胸甲”吧，因为他们佩戴着徽章，那种大大的警长式徽章。他们要在12月20日逮捕“坐牛”，那天是每个人领取口粮的日子，
because everybody will be distracted by getting their rations. They can just swoop in, hoover him up, and take him off to Fort Yates. And the guy who he enlists to do this is a guy called Henry Bullhead. So Bullhead was a Lakota who had once been one of Sitting Bull's warriors, but he subsequently converted to Christianity and sort of puts on trousers and stuff and has become more loyal than the most loyal agency policeman. And actually, Bullhead has a feud with Sitting Bull.
因为每个人都会因为领取口粮而分心。他们可以直接冲进去，把他抓走，带到耶茨堡。他招募来做这件事的人是一个叫亨利·公牛头的人。所以公牛头是一个曾经是“坐牛”战士之一的拉科塔人，但他后来皈依了基督教，穿上了裤子之类的，变得比最忠诚的保留地警察还要忠诚。实际上，公牛头和“坐牛”之间有宿怨。
Sitting Bull's friend catch the bear over a horse, which means that he absolutely loathes Sitting Bull with a passion. So Henry Bullhead is like, great, I can't wait to do this. I'll take charge. But they have to accelerate their timetable very unexpectedly because Sitting Bull, they get word that Sitting Bull is actually planning to go on a little trip. He's going to go and visit the Pine River Reservation,
“坐牛”的朋友“抓熊”因为一匹马的事，这意味着他极其痛恨“坐牛”。所以亨利·公牛头就像是，太好了，我迫不及待要这么做了。我来负责。但他们必须非常意外地加快时间表，因为“坐牛”，他们得到消息说“坐牛”实际上正计划去进行一次小旅行。他要去访问松河保留地，
another reservation. So Bullhead and McLaughlin say, right, we're going to have to hoover up Sitting Bull at once. And Bullhead orders the rest of the police, assemble at my cabin on the night of the 14th of December. So we're approaching now the sort of the great showdown. And his men, the other policemen, arrive at the cabin that evening. And to give you a sense of what sort of people these are, these are Lakota, as you said.
另一个保留地。所以公牛头和麦克劳林说，好吧，我们必须立刻把“坐牛”抓起来。公牛头命令其余警察在12月14日晚上在我的小屋集合。所以我们现在正在接近那场大决战。他的手下，其他警察，那天晚上到达了小屋。为了让你了解这些人是什么样的人，正如你所说，他们是拉科塔人。
So a good example, one of the best accounts we have for this comes from a guy who's called John Lone Man. And Lone Man had fought Custer at the Battle of the Little Bitcoin. He was a Hunkpapa warrior. Yeah. But he had converted to Catholicism and become a farmer and become a kind of agency policeman. And in other words, was your classic kind of good Indian, I suppose, is what people would have called him at the time. And Sitting Bull must in some way serve as a reproach to him. Yeah, of course. A reminder of what he has given up. Totally, Tom. I think that's a really good point. I think for these people, Sitting Bull's insistence that he will not
所以一个很好的例子，我们拥有的关于此事的最好记录之一来自一个叫约翰·孤人的人。孤人曾在小大角战役中与卡斯特作战。他是一名洪克帕帕战士。是的。但他皈依了天主教，成为了一名农民，并成为了一名保留地警察。换句话说，他是当时人们所称的典型的“好印第安人”。而“坐牛”在某种程度上一定是对他的一种责备。是的，当然。提醒他所放弃的一切。完全正确，汤姆。我认为这是一个非常好的观点。我认为对于这些人来说，“坐牛”坚持他不
assimilate, it's a standing rebuke, isn't it? It's a reminder of their own perfidy, I guess. I mean, maybe that's what drives some of the animus against him. Yeah. As they assemble, about 40 of them assemble at Bullhead's cabin. They all gather. Most of them don't speak any English. So a farmer has to translate the orders that they've been given into Lakota. A lot of them are Sitting Bull kind of extended relatives. Sitting Bull's brother-in-law is there.
同化，这是一种持续的责备，不是吗？我想，这提醒了他们自己的背信弃义。我是说，也许这就是驱动一些针对他的敌意的原因。是的。当他们集合时，大约40人聚集在公牛头的小屋里。他们都聚集在一起。他们大多数人不会说英语。所以一个农民必须把他们得到的命令翻译成拉科塔语。他们中很多人是“坐牛”的远房亲戚。“坐牛”的姐夫也在那里。
A nephew of Sitting Bull's is there. And a lot of them are quite anxious and troubled about this. They know it's a kind of slightly shameful thing, I think, that they're doing. They spend the night. They can't sleep. It's obviously freezing out there on the plains. So they're all sort of telling old war stories. I mean, the irony of it, they're telling stories about their own battles against the U.S. Army.
“坐牛”的一个侄子也在那里。他们中很多人对此感到非常焦虑和不安。我想，他们知道这是一种稍微有点可耻的事情。他们度过了那个夜晚。他们睡不着。平原上显然冷得要命。所以他们都在讲旧时的战争故事。我是说，讽刺的是，他们在讲关于他们自己对抗美国军队的战斗的故事。
And then just before dawn, Bullhead leads them in prayers, Christian prayers. Again, a brilliant symbol of the assimilation process. And then at four o'clock in the morning, it's pouring with rain, but they go out in these, it's very sort of bleak scene. I haven't seen that many Westerns to be brutally honest, but I imagine this would be so cinematic. Yeah. It's like the shootout in Unforgiven. Exactly. Like Unforgiven exactly like unforgiven yeah exactly that they ride out in the column four o'clock in the morning it's freezing cold rain pouring down they cross the frozen grand river and they assemble outside sitting bull's cabin so they go into the cabin they push their way in and sitting bull is in bed the different accounts some say
然后在黎明前，公牛头带领他们祈祷，基督教祈祷。这又是同化过程的一个绝佳象征。然后在凌晨四点，大雨倾盆，但他们走进了这些，这场景非常凄凉。老实说，我没看过那么多西部片，但我能想象这会是多么有电影感。是的。就像《不可饶恕》里的枪战。正是如此，就像《不可饶恕》，完全像《不可饶恕》，是的，正是如此，他们列队骑马出发，凌晨四点，天气寒冷，大雨倾盆，他们穿过冰冻的大河，在“坐牛”的小屋外面集合。所以他们走进小屋，强行闯入，“坐牛”在床上，不同的记录，有些人说
lying down or sitting down with one of his wives and a small child and he is totally naked yeah and um sitting bull and goes to reach for a rifle or something and a couple of these guys grab him and they blow out the light and bullhead says to him i've come to take you to the agency you're under arrest and sitting bull gets up and they're sort of pushing him around. And he says sarcastically, oh, this is a great way to do things, not to give me a chance to put on my clothes in winter. And they say, fine, get him some clothes. So his wife goes to the next cabin next door to go and get him some clothes. And as they lead him towards the door, there's already
躺着或坐着，和一个妻子和一个小孩在一起，他完全赤身裸体。是的，嗯，“坐牛”去拿步枪之类的东西，这几个人抓住了他，他们吹灭了灯，公牛头对他说：“我来带你去代理处，你被捕了。”“坐牛”站起来，他们推搡着他。他讽刺地说：“哦，这真是个好办法，不让我有机会在冬天穿上衣服。”他们说：“好吧，给他拿些衣服。”所以他的妻子去隔壁小屋给他拿衣服。当他们把他带向门口时，外面已经
a knot of people assembled outside who are sort of shouting, what have you come for? You know, leave Sitting Bull alone, all this kind of thing. And it's very tense and it's dark. So no one can see what's going on. And tempers are kind of flaring. And then isn't it his son who plays the crucial role in this story? The tragic role. Exactly. So first of all, it's this guy, Catch the Bear, who is a great enemy of Henry Bullhead. And Catch the Bear says, oh, here they are. Oh yeah, we knew they were coming, the metal breasts. What absolute dogs these people are. Yeah.
聚集了一群人，他们在大喊：“你们来干什么？”你知道，“让‘坐牛’一个人待着”，诸如此类的话。气氛非常紧张，而且天很黑。所以没人能看清发生了什么。情绪有点失控。然后，在这个故事中扮演关键角色的不是他的儿子吗？悲剧性的角色。正是如此。所以首先是这个叫“抓熊”的家伙，他是亨利·公牛头的死敌。抓熊说：“哦，他们来了。哦，是的，我们知道他们会来，金属胸甲。这些人真是彻头彻尾的狗。”是的。
You know, we should stand up for our chief. And Sitting Bull at this point, even at this point, is still looking like he's going to go with these guys. You know, he's very anxious and almost a bit befuddled, I think. Obviously, it's the middle of the night, so he's confused. Yeah. But then his son, he has a son called Crowfoot. There are different estimates of his age. He's between 12 Yeah. But then his son, he has a son called Crowfoot. And there are different estimates of his age.
“你知道，我们应该支持我们的首领。”而“坐牛”此时，即使到了这个时候，看起来还是打算和这些人走。你知道，他非常焦虑，几乎有点糊涂，我想。显然，这是半夜，所以他很困惑。是的。但后来他的儿子，他有一个儿子叫“乌鸦脚”。对他年龄的估计各不相同。他大约12岁……是的。但后来他的儿子，他有一个儿子叫“乌鸦脚”。对他年龄的估计各不相同。
He's between 12 and 14, probably. And everyone says of Crowfoot, Crowfoot was very kind of mature for his age. He tried to be one of the adults, not a little boy. Because he is the first generation that can't test himself as a warrior. It's true, Tom. Yeah, it's true. And he's always grown up believing his father Sitting Bull's stories about, you know, you stand up, you don't let yourself be pushed down. And Crowfoot says to Sitting Bull, you always called yourself a brave chief, but now you're allowing yourself to be taken by the metal breasts.
他大概在12到14岁之间。每个人都说“乌鸦脚”，乌鸦脚非常成熟，超出了他的年龄。他试图成为成年人之一，而不是一个小男孩。因为他是第一代不能以战士身份证明自己的人。这是真的，汤姆。是的，这是真的。他从小就相信他父亲“坐牛”关于，你知道，你要站起来，不要让自己被压倒的故事。乌鸦脚对“坐牛”说：“你一直称自己为勇敢的首领，但现在你却让自己被金属胸甲带走。”
And at that, Lone Man said later that that was the point that pushed Sitting Bull over the edge. When his own son, teenage son, says to him, oh, you're not really as big a man as I thought you were. You're a coward. He says, well, actually, I'm not going to go. No, I'm not going. And Lone Man said to him, uncle, nobody's going to harm you. The agent wants to see you and then you'll come back.
在那一刻，孤人后来回忆说，那是把“坐牛”推向深渊的一点。当他自己的儿子，十几岁的儿子，对他说：“哦，你其实没有我想象的那么伟大。你是个懦夫。”他说：“好吧，实际上，我不打算去了。不，我不去了。”孤人对他说：“叔叔，没人会伤害你。探员想见你，然后你就会回来。”
Don't worry. Don't make any trouble. And so they're still in the cabin. People outside are shouting and stuff. A couple of the policemen grab Sitting Bull by the arms and they push him outside. Is he still naked at this point? No, he's got some clothes on, I think. I mean, I picture it with him now clothed.
“别担心。别惹麻烦。”所以他们还在小屋里。外面的人在大喊大叫之类的。几个警察抓住“坐牛”的胳膊，把他推到外面。他此时还是赤身裸体吗？不，我想他穿了一些衣服。我是说，我脑海中他现在是穿着衣服的。
Because they brought him some clothes, haven't they? Yeah. Let's imagine him clothed, Tom, because it's more decorous. But kind of more splendid. You think so? Yeah. Okay. Well, whatever.
因为他们给他带了一些衣服，不是吗？是的。让我们想象他穿着衣服，汤姆，因为这样更得体。但更辉煌。你这么认为吗？是的。好吧，随便吧。
Imagine it as you will. That's the beauty of the rest is history. Sometimes we're vague on the facts so you can imagine them for yourselves. Yeah. We're conjuring an image with words. Yeah. But it's a deliberate choice, isn't it? It's an editorial choice that Tom, rather than a failure of research.
随你怎么想象。这就是《历史的余味》的魅力所在。有时我们对事实含糊其辞，这样你就可以自己想象了。是的。我们用文字勾勒出一幅画面。是的。但这是一种刻意的选择，不是吗？这是一种编辑选择，汤姆，而不是研究上的失败。
Yeah. That's the magic of it. So they grab Sitting Bull by the arms and they kind of semi push him outside. And Bullhead is really clearly anxious and slightly losing patience. Well, because presumably hostile crowds are gathering around, so he's twitchy. Exactly. And he hits Sitting Bull on the back, and he shouts to him,
是的。这就是它的魔力。所以他们抓住“坐牛”的胳膊，把他半推半就地推到外面。公牛头显然非常焦虑，有点失去耐心。嗯，因为大概周围聚集了敌对的人群，所以他很紧张。正是如此。他拍了拍“坐牛”的后背，对他大喊：
you have no ears, you wouldn't listen. And at that, this bloke catch the bear who's on Sitting Bull's side. He just thinks, bring this on. And he throws off this blanket that he had, and there's a rifle underneath, and he shoots at Bullhead. He hits him. And Bullhead, what's really unclear in the melee, in the darkness, is either he does it deliberately, or as he's falling,
“你没有耳朵，你不听劝。”就在那时，这个叫“抓熊”的家伙，站在“坐牛”这一边。他只是想，来吧。他扔掉了他身上的毯子，下面有一把步枪，他向公牛头开枪。他击中了他。而公牛头，在混战中，在黑暗中，非常不清楚的是，要么他是故意这么做的，要么在他倒下时，
he fires his own gun, and it hits Sitting Bull right in the chest. And at that, another bloke called Red Tomahawk is like, oh, right, let's go for it. Let's do it. And he takes his gun and shoots Sitting right in the chest. And at that, another bloke called Red Tomahawk is like, oh, right, let's go for it. Let's do it. And he takes his gun and shoots Sitting Bull in the head. Sitting Bull is down, and now total chaos. Most of the policemen end up taking refuge in the cabin, and there's kind of bullets flying into the walls of the cabin
他开了自己的枪，击中了“坐牛”的胸部。就在那时，另一个叫“红战斧”的家伙就像是，哦，好吧，让我们上吧。让我们做吧。他拿起枪，直接射中了“坐牛”的头部。“坐牛”倒下了，现在是一片混乱。大多数警察最终躲进了小屋，子弹飞进了小屋的墙壁
and the splinters everywhere. And in all this chaos, the other guys are outside blasting away with their rifles lone man sees something crawling along and it's this boy crowfoot and crowfoot says it's a terrible scene crowfoot says my uncles do not kill me i don't want to die and lone man turns to lieutenant bullhead bullhead is still alive he been hit in the stomach, but he's lying there bleeding to death, but he's still kind of compos mentis. And they say, what should we do with this guy, Lieutenant? And Bullhead says, oh, do what you like with him.
到处都是碎片。在这一切混乱中，其他人都在外面用步枪扫射，孤人看到有什么东西在爬，那是那个男孩“乌鸦脚”，乌鸦脚说，这是一个可怕的场景，乌鸦脚说：“我的叔叔们，不要杀我，我不想死。”孤人转向公牛头中尉，公牛头还活着，他腹部中弹，但他躺在那里流血致死，但他仍然有点神志清醒。他们说：“中尉，我们该拿这个家伙怎么办？”公牛头说：“哦，随你便吧。”
He caused all this trouble. So they're like, oh, well, we'll kill him then. So they hit this boy on the head with their rifle butts, and then they shoot him and throw his body out of the door of the cabin. And Dominic, what reputedly adds to the pathos and horror of this episode. And I don't know if it's true, but I've always read it. Yeah.
“他惹了这么多麻烦。”所以他们就像是，哦，好吧，那我们就杀了他。所以他们用步枪枪托击打这个男孩的头部，然后开枪打死他，把他的尸体扔出了小屋的门。多米尼克，是什么据称增加了这一集的悲剧和恐怖。我不知道这是不是真的，但我一直读到它。是的。
Is that his horse, which supposedly had been given to him by Buffalo Bill and had been trained to do kind of dance steps in response to the shooting. Oh my word. At the climax of the show. Yeah. It's supposed to have started doing the dance. That I did not know.
是他的马，据说是布法罗·比尔送给他的，并且被训练成在枪声中跳舞步。天哪。在表演的高潮。是的。它应该已经开始跳舞了。我不知道这一点。
As the bullets are whistling and as Sitting Bull is lying there dead. That's an incredible detail. And, you know, as a kind of coda to the whole tragic story and the fusion of show business with the horrors of what had actually happened, whether it's true or not it
当子弹呼啸而过，“坐牛”躺在那里死去时。这是一个令人难以置信的细节。而且，你知道，作为整个悲剧故事的尾声，以及演艺事业与实际发生的恐怖事件的融合，无论它是真是假，它
should be true definitely should be true if we make this western yeah that would definitely be taking place that's a terrible detail tom and i i'd like to believe it is true because it's such a good twist to the story yeah so whether the horse is dancing or not henry bullhead's men then sort of disgrace themselves i would say well actually maybe they don't by their own standards because people will remember 6 000 episodes ago when we talked about the culture of the Plains and the Plains Indians. And we talked about the habit of mutilating the bodies of your enemies so that they would be poorly equipped to face you in the afterlife. Yeah. Well, I mean, if you've killed Sitting Bull, the greatest warrior of his age,
应该是真的，绝对应该是真的，如果我们拍这部西部片的话，是的，那绝对会发生，这是一个可怕的细节，汤姆，我愿意相信它是真的，因为它给故事增加了一个很好的转折，是的，所以无论马是否在跳舞，亨利·公牛头的手下然后有点丢脸，我会说，嗯，实际上也许按照他们自己的标准并没有，因为人们会记得6000集前我们谈论平原文化和平原印第安人时。我们谈到了肢解敌人尸体的习惯，这样他们就无法在来世面对你。是的。嗯，如果你杀了“坐牛”，他那个时代最伟大的战士，
I mean, you don't want to meet him in your afterlife, do you? And if you do, you want to make sure that he hasn't got any hands or anything. So they just get out their revolvers and they empty them into the body. One man hits him, keeps hacking at his face with an axe. Somebody's cutting him with a knife and another bloke gets a big club or something. And he just basically beats Sitting Bull's head to a pulp. By this point, some of the US army have arrived and the US army are appalled by this scene. And actually there's a soldier who says to them, what the hell are you doing? Leave that man alone. He's dead.
我是说，你不想在来世见到他，对吧？如果你见到了，你想确保他没有手之类的。所以他们只是拿出左轮手枪，把子弹射进尸体里。一个人击中他，继续用斧头砍他的脸。有人用刀割他，另一个人拿了一根大棍子之类的东西。他基本上把“坐牛”的头打成了肉泥。到这个时候，一些美国军队已经到达，美国军队对这一幕感到震惊。实际上有一个士兵对他们说：“你们到底在干什么？让那个人一个人待着。他死了。”
Like, stop it. And the army men take it outside. They have an ambulance or a truck or something, and they want to load it with the dead bodies. And it's actually the metal breasts, the Indian police, who say, we don't want Sitting Bull's body along with our comrades. You know, he's dead to us now as well as being dead. And eventually they compromise that they will put his body in with the others, but he will be upside down, kind of face down as a sign of humiliation
“像，停下。”军队的人把它带到外面。他们有一辆救护车或卡车之类的，他们想装上尸体。实际上是金属胸甲，印第安警察，他们说：“我们不想让‘坐牛’的尸体和我们的同志在一起。”你知道，他现在对我们来说也死了。最终他们妥协了，他们会把他的尸体和其他人放在一起，但他会是倒过来的，脸朝下，作为一种羞辱的标志
while the others are face up. And anyway, that's the end of him. Two days later, they hold the funerals for everybody who died in the shootout because eventually the shootout kind of peters out, Sitting Bull's followers skedaddle. And all the policemen, including Henry Bullhead, who had been shot, are given a sort of big funeral, full military honors, combined Catholic and Protestant service. that is done agent mccloughlin who is there goes to the corner of the cemetery this basically a pauper's grave with a rough wooden coffin and that sitting bull there's no prayers there's no service there's no nothing and no memorial yeah no the only people there are officers in the u.s army who are basically presiding and the grave diggers who are prisoners who are people in the kind of penitentiary they're kind of shovel in a bit of earth, bang, done,
而其他人是脸朝上。总之，这就是他的结局。两天后，他们为在枪战中死去的所有人举行了葬礼，因为最终枪战有点平息了，“坐牛”的追随者逃跑了。所有的警察，包括中弹的亨利·公牛头，都举行了某种盛大的葬礼，全套军事荣誉，天主教和新教联合仪式。那是麦克劳林探员做的，他在那里，走到墓地的角落，这基本上是一个穷人的坟墓，有一个粗糙的木棺材，那是“坐牛”，没有祈祷，没有仪式，什么都没有，也没有纪念碑，是的，没有，那里唯一的人是美国陆军的军官，他们基本上在主持，还有掘墓人，他们是囚犯，是监狱里的人，他们铲了一点土，砰，完了，
that's the end of him. And then you said about the horse. Yeah, because it ends up going on tour, doesn't it? The log cabin. Don't they have a dwarf or something? It does have a dwarf, yeah. I mean, this is that sort of, as the story continued, if you go back to when we first did Custer,
这就是他的结局。然后你说了那匹马。是的，因为它最终去巡演了，不是吗？那个木屋。他们不是有一个侏儒之类的吗？确实有一个侏儒，是的。我是说，这就是那种，随着故事的继续，如果你回到我们第一次做卡斯特的时候，
one of the parallel sort of stories underneath all this, you you know this is the age of the great rise of american capitalism and of course the mass entertainment that goes along with it yeah and actually is the indian wars as the the balance shifts towards the united states and it's clear they're going to win so the wars turn into even while they're happening entertainment entertainment and this happens with sitting bull so the following year some people from Mandan, North Dakota buy his cabin and they transport it to Chicago for the World's Fair. And it is actually billed, it's like a ride, it's like a Disneyland ride. It's billed as Sitting Bull's Death Cabin.
所有这一切之下的平行故事之一，你知道这是美国资本主义大崛起的时代，当然还有随之而来的大众娱乐，是的，实际上是印第安战争，随着天平向美国倾斜，很明显他们会赢，所以战争甚至在发生时就变成了娱乐，娱乐，这发生在“坐牛”身上。所以第二年，一些来自北达科他州曼丹的人买了他的小屋，并把它运到芝加哥参加世界博览会。它实际上被宣传，就像一个游乐设施，就像一个迪士尼乐园的游乐设施。它被称为“坐牛的死亡小屋”。
And they have a Glala there all dressed up. In war paint and feathers and things. Yeah, exactly. Who will show you, oh, here are bullets. And they concoct this kind of cock and bull story about, oh, this bullet was fired by this person. This was Sitting Bull. So where does the dwarf come in? Because then, unbelievably, as if that wasn't, you know, indignity enough, they then say, oh, this is brilliant.
他们有一个奥格拉拉人在那里，打扮得漂漂亮亮。涂着战纹，戴着羽毛之类的。是的，正是如此。谁会向你展示，哦，这里有子弹。他们编造了这种关于，哦，这颗子弹是这个人开的，这是“坐牛”的这种荒诞故事。那么侏儒是从哪里来的呢？因为然后，难以置信地，好像那还不够，你知道，侮辱还不够，他们然后说，哦，这太棒了。
We'll take you to the coney island amusement park and they have a land at coney island called the historic sioux indian war village it has 50 ghost dancers so-called i mean i don't know whether they even are ghost dancers people pretending to do the ghost dance has teepees and it has a female sioux dwarf said to be the only dwarf in the tribe and and as well as Sitting Bull's cabin. And finally, Tom, a nod back to an episode a long time ago where we brought County Cricket into it. They have an exhibition of taxidermy. Oh, right.
“我们带你去康尼岛游乐园”，他们在康尼岛有一块地，叫“历史悠久的苏族印第安战争村”，它有50个所谓的“鬼舞者”，我是说，我不知道他们是否真的是鬼舞者，人们假装跳鬼舞，有圆锥形帐篷，还有一个苏族女性侏儒，据说是部落里唯一的侏儒，还有“坐牛”的小屋。最后，汤姆，向很久以前我们把县板球引入其中的一集致敬。他们有一个动物标本展览。哦，对了。
Of stuffed animals. So what, buffalo? So I guess buffalo, bison, like plains animal, foxes, you know, who knows? Yeah. So they're also being wiped out. I mean, the one consolation from this terrible story is they didn't stuff Sitting Bull. Yeah. Because I wouldn't put it past them.
填充动物。所以什么，水牛？所以我猜是水牛，野牛，像平原动物，狐狸，你知道，谁知道呢？是的。所以它们也被消灭了。我是说，这个可怕故事中唯一的一点安慰是他们没有把“坐牛”做成标本。是的。因为我不会觉得他们做不出来。
Anyway, that's the end of poor old Sitting Bull. What a terrible story. And what is the impact on the Lakota? I think a lot of the Lakota, some of them are glad to see him go. Gawle and his collaborators, like, yeah, he's a load off our minds. He was just a terrible drag and a pain. But I think most of them deep down, it is a further sign of their kind of, I feel harsh using these words because they're so loaded, but it's almost that they've been kind of
总之，这就是可怜的“坐牛”的结局。多么可怕的故事。这对拉科塔人有什么影响？我认为很多拉科塔人，有些人很高兴看到他离开。高尔和他的合作者，就像，是的，他让我们松了一口气。他只是一个可怕的拖累和痛苦。但我认为他们内心深处，大多数人，这是他们那种，我觉得用这些词很刺耳，因为它们太沉重了，但几乎就像他们已经被
spiritually emasculated, cut off from their heritage, cut off from their history. You know, this guy who was perceived as being the symbol of authenticity and integrity. I mean, of course, we can debate about how much that is a construct. But for him to be gone, I mean, that's why L. Frank Baum writes that editorial. Yeah, because it's in the wake of that, isn't it? Because the end of Sitting Bull feels like,
精神上阉割了，与他们的遗产隔绝，与他们的历史隔绝。你知道，这个被视为真实性和完整性象征的家伙。我是说，当然，我们可以争论这在多大程度上是一个建构。但他离开了，我是说，这就是L·弗兰克·鲍姆写那篇社论的原因。是的，因为它是在那之后，不是吗？因为“坐牛”的终结感觉就像，
bang, that is the end of the story, the whole story. Although, of course, it isn't. It isn't. So, Dominic, should we take a break now? Yeah. And when we come back, we will look at the, well, it's a masker, isn't it? That is effectively the end of this story isn't. It isn't. So, Dominic, should we take a break now? Yeah. And when we come back, we will look at the,
砰，故事到此结束，这就是全部。当然，事实并非如此。并非如此。那么，多米尼克，我们现在休息一下好吗？好的。当我们回来时，我们将看看，嗯，这是一个面具，不是吗？这实际上是这个故事的结局，不是吗？并非如此。那么，多米尼克，我们现在休息一下好吗？好的。当我们回来时，我们将看看，
well, it's a masker, isn't it, that is effectively the end of this story. Yeah, the story of Wounded Knee and the end of the ghost dance. So we'll do that after the break, Tom.
嗯，这是一个面具，不是吗，这实际上是这个故事的结局。是的，伤膝河的故事和鬼舞的终结。所以我们休息后再谈这个，汤姆。
I'm Marina Hyde. And I'm Richard Osman. And together we host The Rest Is Entertainment. It's your weekly fix of entertainment news, reviews, splash of showbiz gossip
我是玛丽娜·海德。我是理查德·奥斯曼。我们共同主持《其余皆娱乐》。这是您每周必看的娱乐新闻、评论和一点点演艺圈八卦。
and on our q a we pull back the curtain on entertainment and we tell you how it all works we have just launched our members club if you want ad-free listening bonus episodes and early access to live tickets head to the very last segment of what has turned out to be an 11-episode sweep through the story of Custer, Crazy Horse, Sitting Bull. By this point in the story, they are all dead. The United States has comprehensively won. The Lakota are a beaten people. But Dominic, there is one last confrontation to come, isn't there?
在我们的问答环节中，我们将揭开娱乐界的帷幕，告诉您这一切是如何运作的。我们刚刚推出了会员俱乐部，如果您想要无广告收听、额外剧集和抢先购买现场演出门票，请前往我们这11集系列节目的最后一部分，我们讲述了卡斯特、疯马和坐牛的故事。故事讲到这里，他们都已经去世了。美国已经全面获胜。拉科塔人是一个被打败的民族。但是多米尼克，还有最后一场对抗要发生，不是吗？
There is. So some people will be familiar with the book by Dee Brown that was published at the beginning of the 70s called Bury My Heart at Wounded Knee. And that was the book that really transformed. I think it's now regarded as a bit outdated, isn't it, Tom? I think it's regarded though- As a classic. As a highly significant book in terms of how this kind of clash is understood totally it was transformative because the story of how the west was won is now kind of how the west was lost exactly it was absolutely
确实如此。有些人可能熟悉迪·布朗在70年代初出版的那本书，书名叫《魂归伤膝河》。那本书确实改变了人们的看法。我想现在它被认为有点过时了，不是吗，汤姆？但我认为它被视为——一部经典之作。作为一本在理解这种冲突方面具有高度重要意义的书，它完全是变革性的，因为“西部是如何被征服的”这个故事，现在变成了“西部是如何失去的”，确实，它绝对是
transformative in the way people viewed that balance between americans and native americans for want of a better phrase and it and he obviously got the title from the poem that you quoted in the previous episode. Yeah. But this idea of wounded knee as this terrible scar, psychological scar, and the end point, the end point of the whole story. And that's really what we're building up to now. So Sitting Bull, you mentioned, you know, what did the Lakota make of the death of Sitting Bull
变革性的，改变了人们看待美国人和美洲原住民之间平衡的方式（如果用这个词的话）。他显然是从你在上一集引用的那首诗中得到的书名。是的。但这种将伤膝河视为可怕伤疤、心理创伤以及整个故事终点的想法，正是我们现在要铺垫的内容。所以坐牛，你提到了，你知道，拉科塔人对坐牛之死有何看法
just before the break? Sitting Bull's kind of following his people, his relatives and stuff. They all flee in panic after his death. And they flee to a village on the Cheyenne River, which has a chief called Bigfoot. Now, Bigfoot has been very into the ghost dance, but he's actually a moderate kind of person.
就在休息之前？坐牛某种程度上是在追随他的人民、亲戚等等。他在死后，他们都惊慌失措地逃跑了。他们逃到了夏延河边的一个村庄，那里有一位酋长叫大脚。大脚一直很热衷于鬼舞，但他实际上是一个温和的人。
He's well-known as somebody who will make peace. And he's actually, therefore, quite a good person to go to because he should be able to negotiate with the government, with the agency officials and so on. General Miles, who is still lurking around with his troops, he's quite anxious that Bigfoot is out there, and he says, right, we need to bring Bigfoot in. We need to get his village,
他以爱好和平而闻名。因此，他实际上是一个很好的谈判对象，因为他应该能够与政府、代理机构官员等进行协商。迈尔斯将军，他仍然带着部队在附近徘徊，他非常担心大脚在外面，他说，好吧，我们需要把大脚带回来。我们需要找到他的村庄，
and we need to escort these people to a fort where we can basically have them under surveillance, and we can sort them out and then assimilate them back into the reservation. But instead of coming back to a fort as planned, just before Christmas, Bigfoot's camp, which is now about 300 people, they have an escort, military escort,
我们需要护送这些人到一个堡垒，在那里我们可以基本上对他们进行监视，我们可以处理他们，然后将他们重新同化回保留地。但就在圣诞节前，大脚的营地（现在大约有300人）并没有像计划的那样回到堡垒，他们有护送，军事护送，
but they slip away from the escort and they head off randomly across the plains. And actually what they're doing is they're a bit frightened. They're worried that they're being lured into a trap at this fort, which they probably weren't. But you can see why they think that. Oh, totally. You can see why they think it.
但他们从护送中溜走了，随机地穿过平原。实际上他们这样做是因为他们有点害怕。他们担心自己被诱骗到那个堡垒的陷阱里，虽然他们可能并没有。但你可以理解他们为什么会这么想。哦，完全可以。你可以理解他们为什么会这么想。
Looking at what happened to Crazy Horse and Sitting Bull. Correct. It's not unreasonable that they think that at all. And they say, we're going to go to a different reservation, the Pine Ridge Reservation. Red Cloud, who's now 640, he's there and he will be able to look after us. And so the commanders send more troops to ram these guys up. They say, well, we can't have these guys just roaming randomly across the sort of the center of America. Go and get them. So it's absolutely freezing cold. So it's December in the sort of South Dakota, Nebraska borderlands. It's really bleak. I mean, this adds to the sort
看看疯马和坐牛的遭遇。没错。他们有这种想法一点也不不合理。他们说，我们要去另一个保留地，松岭保留地。红云，现在已经640岁了，他在那里，他能照顾我们。于是指挥官派了更多部队去拦截这些人。他们说，好吧，我们不能让这些人就这样在美洲中部随机游荡。去把他们抓回来。天气冷得要命。那是12月，在南达科他州和内布拉斯加州的边界地带。真的很凄凉。我的意思是，这增加了那种
of the atmosphere. Somber quality of the story. Exactly. Exactly, Tom. The troops are looking for these guys and the troops make camp at a place called Wounded Knee Creek, which is right in those borderlands and the snow falling and everything and everybody's cold and miserable and their mood is very gloomy. And on the 28th of December, their scouts say we've spotted Bigfoot's people. Actually, Bigfoot's people are in an incredibly bad way. Bigfoot himself has got pneumonia in the winter. He's incredibly ill. And basically, he and his people have given up hope.
氛围。故事的阴郁基调。正是如此。正是如此，汤姆。部队正在寻找这些人，部队在伤膝河边扎营，就在那些边界地带，雪花飘落，每个人都又冷又痛苦，情绪非常低落。12月28日，他们的侦察兵说我们发现了大脚的人。实际上，大脚的人处境极其糟糕。大脚本人在冬天患了肺炎。他病得非常重。基本上，他和他的人民已经放弃了希望。
And they've actually decided they're going to come in after all. And what they're going to do is they want to come and join up with us, the army, so we can all go together to the Pine Ridge agency. And the scouts say they're hungry. They haven't eaten for days. They're just sort of in r for days they're just sort of in rags and they're huddled in blankets a lot of them are ill you know they're a really pitiful scene but they're very anxious and nervous they know they've run away from their escort they're worried
他们实际上已经决定无论如何都要投降了。他们打算做的是加入我们，军队，这样我们就可以一起去松岭代理处。侦察兵说他们很饿。他们已经好几天没吃东西了。他们只是……他们只是衣衫褴褛，裹着毯子，很多人都病了，你知道，这是一个非常可怜的场景，但他们非常焦虑和紧张，他们知道他们从护送中逃跑了，他们担心
they're in trouble and all this so the commander's like okay we'll find we'll tell them to come in so they find that evening bigfoot's people turn up, 300 of them, very miserable sort of spectacle kind of, you know, it's like the sort of the exodus of the Israelites or something. And the army give them some food and they set up a cordon around them so they can't get away. And at that point, army reinforcements arrive. So that evening and as luck would have it, the army reinforcements are the second battalion of the 7th Cavalry. They're commanded by a guy called Colonel Forsyth. And so now what we have is almost 500 soldiers.
他们有麻烦了，诸如此类。所以指挥官说，好吧，我们会找到他们的，告诉他们进来。那天晚上，大脚的人出现了，300人，非常凄惨的景象，你知道，就像以色列人的出埃及记之类的。军队给了他们一些食物，并在他们周围设置了警戒线，这样他们就无法逃脱。就在那时，军队增援部队到达了。那天晚上，幸运的是，军队增援部队是第7骑兵团的第二营。他们由一个叫福赛斯上校的人指挥。所以现在我们有近500名士兵。
And they have, by the way, these guns called Hotchkiss guns, which are kind of like machine guns mounted on carts or trolleys or something. So the kind that Custer had not taken. Exactly. Yes, exactly right. Am I right in thinking that the members of the 7th Cavalry who are there, they're all kind of raw recruits. They are. They haven't really had combat experience, but obviously they've been raised on stories
顺便说一句，他们有这些叫霍奇基斯炮的枪，有点像安装在马车或手推车上的机枪。就是卡斯特没带的那种？没错。是的，完全正确。我没记错的话，在场的第7骑兵团成员都是新兵，对吧？是的。他们并没有真正的战斗经验，但显然他们是在关于
of the massacre of the 7th Cavalry. Totally. Yeah. So they're kind of itching for vengeance, itching to win battle honours of the 7th Cavalry. Totally, yeah. So they're kind of itching for vengeance, itching to win battle honours for the 7th Cavalry that will redeem its lost honour. Yeah. And also a sense that the people that they're facing
第7骑兵团大屠杀的故事中长大的。完全正确。是的。所以他们渴望复仇，渴望为第7骑兵团赢得战斗荣誉。完全正确，是的。所以他们渴望复仇，渴望为第7骑兵团赢得战斗荣誉，以洗刷其失去的荣誉。是的。而且还有一种感觉，他们面对的人
are inveterately savage and dangerous. Yeah, exactly, exactly, Tom. So a very large proportion of them have literally never fired a gun before. They are the rawest of recruits. But as some historians say, this is the generation now that have grown up being pumped with adventure stories, dare I say, cowboys and Indians. Now, as we said in the previous episode, cowboys never fought Indians because they came in after the Indians had been driven out. But these are probably the first people who have grown up reading these stories
是根深蒂固的野蛮和危险的。是的，没错，没错，汤姆。所以他们中很大一部分人真的从来没开过枪。他们是最新的新兵。但正如一些历史学家所说，这是成长过程中被灌输冒险故事的一代，我敢说是“牛仔和印第安人”。现在，正如我们在上一集所说，牛仔从未与印第安人战斗过，因为他们是在印第安人被驱逐后才来的。但这些人可能是第一批成长过程中阅读这些故事的人，
and obsessed with the idea of the cruelty and savagery of the Indians. But also that it's becoming a myth, isn't it? Yeah. That Custer's last stand has already become a myth. Exactly. I think there in the 7th Cavalry is exactly that. They know that this is Custer's,
并且沉迷于印第安人的残忍和野蛮的想法。但也变成了一个神话，不是吗？是的。卡斯特的最后之战已经变成了一个神话。没错。我想第7骑兵团里正是如此。他们知道这就是卡斯特的，
they're Custer's boys, kind of posthumously. A scalp for Custer. That's what they're talking about. And so that night, the soldiers are sitting up getting absolutely wasted, drinking, and they're talking about, were any of these people at the Bighorn? Which one do you reckon was at the Bighorn? All of this kind of thing. And actually, some of the Lakota who lived to tell the tale said that that night, they
他们是卡斯特的男孩，某种意义上是死后的。为卡斯特剥头皮。这就是他们在谈论的。那天晚上，士兵们坐着喝得烂醉，他们在谈论，这些人里有没有人在大角河之战？你觉得哪个在大角河？诸如此类。实际上，一些幸存下来的拉科塔人说，那天晚上，他们
would come up to them and point guns at them and say, were you at the Bighorn? Were you at the fight with Custer? You know, kind of drunkenly. So it's quite an intimidating scene. Morning break, so we're at the 30th of December now. Somehow I skipped a day there, but we can live with that. Actually, since we're at episode 11, nobody's listening anyway. So it's freezing cold and snow is falling
会走到他们面前，用枪指着他们说，你在大角河吗？你参加了与卡斯特的战斗吗？你知道，醉醺醺地。所以这是一个相当吓人的场景。早晨休息，现在是12月30日了。不知怎么我跳过了一天，但我们可以接受。实际上，既然我们已经到了第11集，反正也没人听。天气冷得要命，雪花飘落，
and it's an incredibly kind of bleak and cheerless scene. And Colonel Forsyth rounds up Bigfoot's people and he positions his troopers around them in a circle. Which is quite Custer coming across the Dakota or Cheyenne village, isn't it? Yeah, the Washita, the massacre of the Washitatum. So he says, before we move off i really must take all your weapons and um so his troops are all around them but it's very difficult for him to get order bigfoot is too ill so bigfoot's just kind of huddled up in a kind of bed somewhere a lot of the men are in their ghost dance shirts and they're kind of wandering about
这是一个极其凄凉和毫无生气的场景。福赛斯上校把大脚的人围起来，把他的骑兵排成一个圆圈。这很像卡斯特在达科他或夏延村遇到的情况，不是吗？是的，沃希托，沃希托大屠杀，汤姆。所以他说，在我们出发之前，我真的必须收缴你们所有的武器，嗯……所以他的部队都在他们周围，但他很难维持秩序。大脚病得太重了，所以大脚只是蜷缩在某个地方的床上。很多男人穿着他们的鬼舞衬衫，他们有点漫无目的地走来走去，
randomly and it's all very you know it's got a cross between a kind of battle and a kind of rock festival and a sort of scout camp or something or a refugee camp i suppose would be the analogy yeah it's just really hard for him to be heard so finally he very sort of stridently he manages to assert his authority and he says right i want all your guns, the guns are so important to them. For them, the gun, ownership of the gun is like owning a horse or something. It's so precious to you. It is your identity. And a marker of your dignity.
随机地，这真的很……你知道，它介于一场战斗、一个摇滚音乐节、一个童子军营地或一个难民营之间，我想这应该是类比。是的，他很难被听到。所以最后，他非常严厉地设法维护了他的权威，他说，好吧，我要你们所有的枪。枪对他们来说太重要了。对他们来说，拥有枪就像拥有马一样。它对你来说太珍贵了。它是你的身份。也是你尊严的标志。
A dignity. And it's very expensive. It's probably one of the most single, if not the single most expensive thing you own. And so a lot of these guys are very reluctant to give over their guns. And a lot of them are actually hiding their weapons. They've deliberately hidden their weapons under blankets and in boxes and stuff. And so there's a bit of a standoff. And Colonel Forsyth says, if you're not going to surrender your guns, this is a complete shambles. We're going to start to search you personally. We're going to search you. We're going to make you lift
一种尊严。而且它非常昂贵。它可能是你拥有的最昂贵的东西，如果不是唯一最昂贵的话。所以这些人中很多都不愿意交出他们的枪。而且他们中很多人实际上在藏匿武器。他们故意把武器藏在毯子下、盒子里等等。所以出现了一些僵持。福赛斯上校说，如果你不打算交出枪支，这简直是一团糟。我们要开始搜身了。我们要搜查你们。我们要让你们掀起
your blankets to show that you don't have any guns. And he sends some soldiers forward to do this. They search, by some accounts, three guys, and then they approach another guy called Black Coyote. Black Coyote is a younger warrior, but he's also deaf. And he holds his gun over his head. It's a Winchester, and he says, I've paid a lot of money for this gun. I don't understand what's going on because obviously he's deaf,
你们的毯子，证明你们没有任何枪支。他派了一些士兵上前做这件事。据一些说法，他们搜查了三个人，然后他们接近了另一个叫黑狼的人。黑狼是一个年轻的战士，但他也是聋子。他把枪举过头顶。那是一把温彻斯特步枪，他说，我花了很多钱买这把枪。我不明白发生了什么，因为显然他是聋子，
but there's no way I'm giving you my gun because you'll have to pay me for it. Some soldiers come to him. It degenerates pretty quickly into a struggle for the gun. At some point, it's hard to tell exactly what happens but the gun goes off and a shot goes up into the sky into the icy air and at that point an army scout or either just before just after it's hard to tell shouts look out they're shooting they're shooting and the commanding officer colonel forsy, just loses it completely. Because everything has presumably prepped him to lose it.
但无论如何我也不会给你我的枪，因为你得付钱给我。一些士兵走向他。这很快演变成了一场争夺枪支的斗争。在某个时刻，很难说到底发生了什么，但枪走火了，一颗子弹射向了冰冷的天空。就在那一刻，一名军队侦察兵，或者就在之前或之后，很难说，大喊“小心，他们在开枪，他们在开枪”。指挥官福赛斯上校完全失去了理智。因为一切大概都让他准备好失去理智了。
I guess so, Tom. You're being very generous. I mean, they have worked themselves up into a state where they think they are confronting dangerous hostiles. Yes, of course. And they are doing it in the context of everything that had gone before. They think that they are still a part of this history that they are so familiar with. I guess. Yeah, you're right. You're right. And actually the comparison is with, think of so many imperial massacres in history by colonial forces against, you know, occupying forces. Yeah. But I think particularly with this, that sense of the drama of this great period of
我想是这样，汤姆。你太慷慨了。我的意思是，他们已经把自己逼到了一个认为自己正在面对危险敌人的状态。是的，当然。而且他们是在之前发生的一切背景下这样做的。他们认为自己仍然是他们如此熟悉的历史的一部分。我想是这样。是的，你是对的。你是对的。实际上，这可以与历史上殖民军队对占领军进行的许多帝国大屠杀相比较。是的。但我认为特别是这一点，那种戏剧感，在这个伟大的历史时期，双方一直在相互较量，而现在这一切都结束了，就好像双方的人都无法忍受让它结束一样。是的，我明白你的意思，你可以理解鬼舞，你知道，你会想要相信水牛会回来，白人会离开，一切会回到原来的样子。但你不认为美国军队方面也有一种感觉，仅仅是巡逻难民并把他们围起来，比起骑马冲进战场面对坐牛或疯马，
history where the two sides have been matching each other and now that has gone and it's almost as though people on both sides can't bear to let it go yeah i can see what you're saying that you can understand that with the ghost dance you know you'd want to believe that there's a possibility that the buffalo will come back that the white people will go that it will go back to being the way it was but don't you think there's possibly also a sense on the part of the American army that just to kind of patrol refugees and coral them up is kind of demeaning compared to riding into battle and coming up against Sitting Bull or Crazy Horse
或那种级别的战士，是一种贬低吗？我的意思是，有点像拉科塔的年轻男孩想要证明自己。你知道，第7骑兵团有新一代，他们也想感觉自己是这个故事的一部分，你不觉得吗？我确实这么认为，汤姆。我认为你是绝对正确的。
or warriors of that calibre. I mean, a bit like the young boys of the Lakota wanting to prove themselves. You know, there's a new generation of the 7th Cavalry and they want to feel that they are part of this story too, don't you think? I do, Tom. I think that you're absolutely right.
我认为在某种意义上，那里的每个人都在……以他们一直以来的方式演戏。是的。所以布法罗·比尔的东西，坐牛的小屋被带去巡回演出等等，它正在变成一种戏剧，现在他们又回到了其中。我完全同意你的看法。我认为有一种角色扮演的成分，特别是来自
I think there's a sense in which everybody there is... Kind of play acting in the way that they have been. Yeah. So the Buffalo Bill stuff and the Sitting Bull cabin being taken on tour and things, it's becoming a kind of drama and now they're back in it. I completely agree with you. I think there's an element of the kind of role playing going on, particularly from the
第七骑兵团。我们在上次谈到的新闻报道中也看到了这一点，预测这场伟大的印第安战争。他们想相信会发生什么。但还有，我不知道，在这个故事中，我总觉得如此多的伟大传奇都是在非常戏剧性的彩色场景中上演的，在炎热、尘土和光线中。而现在它是单色的。
Seventh Cavalry. It was also there in the press reports that we talked about last time, predicting this great Indian war. They wanted to believe that something was going to happen. But also, I don't know, it always seems to me with this story that so much of the great saga has been played out in very dramatic technicolor scenes, in baking heat and dust and light. And now it's monochrome.
是的，非常黑暗、寒冷、下雪、可悲且凄凉的结局。那是雪地上的血。雪地上的血，是的。所以士兵们，当福赛斯大喊时，开始射击，向他们开火，士兵们立即，就像历史上许多大屠杀一样，他们只是开始射击，然后它变得具有传染性。当然，非凡的事情是，他把他的部下围成了一个圆圈。
Yeah, really dark, cold, snowy, pathetic and bleak ending. And it's the blood on snow. The blood on the snow, yeah. So the soldiers, when Forsyth's shouted, start shooting fire, fire on them, the soldiers immediately, as in so many massacres in history, they just start shooting and then it becomes infectious. The extraordinary thing is, of course, he has put his men in a circle.
士兵们在互相残杀。所以这是他的指挥官对他感到愤怒的事情之一，实际上士兵们在混乱中互相射击。这太肮脏了，不是吗？友军误伤，妇女和儿童死亡。我的意思是，这简直是最糟糕的。但在中间，300人，有玩游戏的孩子，有玩跳马的男孩。
The soldiers are killing each other. So this is one of the things that outrages his commanders about this, is that actually soldiers shoot each other in the chaos. It's so squalid, isn't it? Friendly fire, women and children dead. I mean, it's kind of the worst. But in the middle, 300 people, there were children playing games, there were boys playing leapfrog.
玩跳马的男孩都立即死了。他们被子弹撕碎了。在那一刻，那些有武器的苏族人，也就是刀、棍棒，有些人确实有隐藏的枪，或者他们从士兵那里抢枪，他们试图反击。它立刻演变成了一场可怕的流血狂欢。当然，士兵们，在这最初的几分钟里发生的事情证实了士兵们的怀疑，对吧？我们正在面对这些极其野蛮的人，他们要对我们下手。他们就像，哦，他们确实这样做了。
The boys who play leapfrog all die immediately. They're just torn apart by bullets. At that point, those Sioux who have weapons, so knives, clubs, some of them do have hidden guns, or they grab guns from soldiers, they try to fight back. And it just degenerates straight away into this horrendous sort of orgy of bloodshed. And the soldiers, of course, what happens in this first few moments confirms what the soldiers suspected, right? That we are facing these dreadfully savage people and they're going to turn on us. And they're like, oh, they have.
所以他们变得更加无情。炮兵使用了这些机枪，这些霍奇基斯炮，它们正在疯狂扫射。正如你所说，我的意思是，难民就是这个词。他们正在扫射这些手无寸铁的难民。很多人试图逃跑。他们跑进了一个峡谷，但士兵们随后用机枪向峡谷里扫射，
So they become even more relentless. The artillery use these machine guns, these Hotchkiss guns, and they are just ripping through. As you said, I mean, refugees is the word. They're ripping through these unarmed refugees. Lots of people try to run for it. They run into a ravine, but the soldiers then take the machine guns and fire down into the ravine
杀死了所有躲在那里的人。即使妇女和儿童从峡谷里爬出来，骑兵也跟着他们，向他们射击。就像黑水壶在沃希托被杀一样，大脚不是也被击中背部了吗？他被击中背部，他的女儿也是。哦，他的女儿也一样。他先是被击中背部。她跑到他的尸体旁，他被击中背部，不是吗？他被击中背部，他的女儿也是。哦，他的女儿也一样。他先是被击中背部，她跑到他的尸体旁，他们向她的背部射击。那些幸存下来的人，所以几乎所有的男人都被杀了，嗯，妇女和儿童，他们试图在
to kill all the people hiding there. Even when women and children crawl out of the ravine, troopers follow them, shooting at them. And just as Black Kettle, Rashida, was killed, isn't Bigfoot, he's shot in the back, isn't he? He's shot in the back and so is his daughter. Oh, his daughter too. He's shot in the back first. She runs to his body and he's shot in the back isn't he shot in the back and so is his daughter oh his daughter too he's shot in the back first she runs to his body and they shoot her in the back those who survive so almost all the men are killed um women and children they try to take
周围的峡谷等地避难，士兵们开火，他们开火，继续开火，他们跟着他们，当他们发现成堆的尸体，当他们发现有小孩子在动时。我的意思是，公平地说，卡斯特的行为比这好。卡斯特试图阻止沃希托大屠杀。他试图阻止他的部下杀害妇女和儿童。在这种情况下，显然有一种默许的鼓励。“消灭所有野蛮人”。没错。我们现在必须消灭所有人。
refuge in the sort of surrounding canyons and things and the soldiers fire they fire keep firing they follow them when they find piles of bodies, when they find children, small children moving. I mean, fair to point out, Custer behaved better than that. Custer tried to restrain the Washita massacre. He tried to restrain his men from killing women and children. In this case, there's clearly a sort of tacit encouragement. Exterminate all the brutes. Correct. We must now eliminate everybody.
我的意思是，这实际上是一个可怕的故事。所以一些列兵感到震惊。就像在任何大屠杀中一样，有些人感到震惊。这个列兵，当枪声平息时，在妇女和儿童的尸体堆旁边，他发现了两个婴儿，他们还活着。他把他们抱起来，开始把他们带到一个昨晚为难民设立的医院帐篷里，一个中士遇到了他，他说，嗯，你到底在干什么？他说，把他们的脑袋砸在树上，否则有一天他们会和我们战斗。那个列兵感到震惊，他对他的中士说，我
I mean, it's a terrible story, actually. So some of the privates are shocked. As in any mean, there's a terrible story actually. So some of the privates are shocked. As in any massacre, there are some people who are appalled. And this private, as the firing is dying down, next to a pile of bodies of women and children, he finds two babies and they are still alive. And he picks them up and he starts to carry them off to a kind of hospital tent that had been set up overnight for the refugees and a sergeant meets him and he says um what the hell are you doing he says smash their brains out against a tree because otherwise someday they'll be fighting us and the private is horrified and he says to his sergeant i would
宁愿砸你也不愿砸这些孩子。但那里的大多数人并不那样想。所以他们幸免于难了吗？那两个孩子幸免于难，是的。但他们是少数，因为在场的350多人中，约有300人被杀。他们的尸体，士兵们在冻土中挖了一条沟，然后把所有的尸体扔进了一个乱葬坑。这就是伤膝河大屠杀。当消息传回说发生了这件事时，
rather smash you than smash these children but most people there didn't think like that so are they spared those two kids are spared, yeah. But they're a minority because of the 350-odd people who were there, about 300 of them are killed. And their bodies, the soldiers hack a kind of a trench into the frozen ground and then they throw all the bodies in in a mass grave. And that is the massacre of Wounded Knee. And when word got back that this had happened,
显然消息几乎立即传开了，迈尔斯将军，我们之前说过，是一个非常有野心的人，果断、无情、强硬。正如我们之前所说，他娶了谢尔曼的侄女，谢尔曼将军的侄女。他写信给他的妻子说，这是最令人憎恶的刑事军事失误，是一场可怕的妇女和儿童大屠杀。他对此感到非常震惊。
so obviously word travels almost immediately, General Miles, who is, we said before, a very ambitious man, decisive, ruthless, a hard man. He was married, as we said before, to Sherman's niece, General Sherman's niece. And he wrote to his wife and said it was the most abominable criminal military blunder, a horrible massacre of women and children. He is absolutely appalled by it.
迈尔斯，值得称赞的是，他说，我们必须进行一次大规模调查。你知道，正如人们所说，必须有人负责。这是完全不可接受的。你知道，他对此感到震惊。但实际上已经太晚了，因为第一批新闻报道已经传回去了。你看，有记者和士兵在一起。就像一直以来的那样。而所有这些时间里，记者们一直在煽动整个鬼舞歇斯底里。
Miles, to his credit, says, we must have a big inquiry. You know, as it were, heads must roll. This is totally unacceptable. You know, he's horrified by it. But it's actually too late because the first press reports have already gone back. There were journalists, you see, with the soldiers. As there always had been. And all of this time, the journalists have been ramping up the whole ghost dance hysteria.
多米尼克，你说过很多勇士，嗯，他们不再是勇士了，对吧？男人们，穿着鬼舞衬衫。是的。据说可以挡子弹，但并没有。我们现在有确凿的证据证明鬼舞不起作用。为那些希望它们能起作用的人感到遗憾，它没有。所以第一批记者之一，威廉·凯利，他当时在《林肯州日报》，他说，哦，印第安人先开枪，印第安人攻击我们。
And Dominic, you said that lots of the Braves, well they're not Braves anymore are they? The men, were wearing ghost dance shirts. Yes. Which supposedly could stop bullets and they didn't. We now have definitive proof that the ghost dance did not work. Sorry for those people who were hoping that they might have worked, it didn't. So one of the first journalists, William Kelly, who was with the Lincoln State Journal, he said, oh the Indians shot first, the Indians attacked us.
天黑之前，我怀疑大脚部落里是否还会剩下任何男人或女人来讲述这一天背叛的故事。第7骑兵团的成员再次证明了自己是勇敢的英雄。我的意思是，写下关于这显然只是一场可怕大屠杀的事情是一件可怕的事情。但大多数美国人在当时想相信这一点。他们被训练去相信它，而且他们渴望报复，对吧？这是第7骑兵团，卡斯特的团。但只有在面对危险敌人时才叫报复。当然。所以这就是他们必须被告知的。但人们说，好吧，它开始传出去了，有很多妇女和儿童。但《纽约论坛报》说，一个苏族女人和男人一样是坏敌人，小男孩可以像他们的父亲一样射击。
Before night, I doubt if either a buck or a square out of all Bigfoot's band will be left to tell the tale of this day's treachery. The members of the 7th Cavalry have once more shown themselves to be heroes in deeds of daring. I mean, a terrible thing to write about what was obviously just such a horrific massacre. But most Americans want to believe that at the time. They'd be conditioned to believe it, but also they're itching for payback, right? It's the 7th Cavalry, Custer's regiment. But it's only payback if they're facing dangerous hostiles. Of course. And so that's what they have to be told. But people say, well, it starts to get out, there's a lot of women and children. But the New York Tribune, a Sioux squaw is as bad an enemy as a man, and the little boys can shoot quite as well as their fathers.
换句话说，是的，当然，他们是妇女和儿童，但他们仍然是公平的目标。杀了他们所有人。所以他们举行了调查。福赛斯上校被洗清了罪名。迈尔斯对此感到愤怒。我的意思是，令人震惊的是，实际上军队的高层比平民更警觉于军队所作所为的肮脏本质。
In other words, yeah, sure, they're women and children, but they're still fair game. Kill them all. So they held an inquiry. Colonel Forsyth was cleared. Miles was furious at this. I mean, it's striking how it is actually the high command in the army who are much more alert to the squalid nature of what the army has been
平民在整个故事中，政客们大体上都丢尽了脸。我的意思是，一个完美的例子，战争部长，本杰明·哈里森的战争部长，一个叫雷德菲尔德·普罗克特的家伙。经典。两个姓氏而不是一个名字和一个姓氏。总是一个坏兆头。总是一个坏兆头，总是一个坏兆头，他说，嗯，军官和士兵在整个事件中的行为证明了第七骑兵团处于极其令人满意的纪律状态。他们的行为表现出技巧、冷静、谨慎、克制，并为他们的团赢得了尽可能高的荣誉。我的意思是，令人难以置信，绝对令人难以置信。绝对令人难以置信。
up to than the civilians. The civilians throughout this whole story, the politicians by and large, disgrace themselves. I mean, a perfect example, the secretary of war, Benjamin Harrison's secretary of war guy called Redfield Proctor. Classic. Two surnames instead of one first name and a name. Always a bad sign. Always a bad sign always a bad sign he said um the conduct of both officers and men throughout the whole affair demonstrates an exceedingly satisfactory state of discipline in the seventh cavalry their behavior was characterized by skill coolness discretion forbearance and reflects the highest possible credit upon their regiment i mean incredible absolutely incredible. Absolutely incredible.
所以伤膝河大屠杀没有任何后果。鬼舞生意在那之后基本上立即消失了。迈尔斯将军的组合，也就是军队自1870年代以来成功使用的胡萝卜加大棒的组合。他收紧了保留地周围的警戒线，围捕了任何掉队者。但他说是，如果你回到保留地，如果你放弃这种鬼舞胡闹，我们会宽大处理。我们会给你们食物。我们甚至会给你们礼物。我们会给你们津贴等等。
So there were no consequences from the Massacre of the Ruined Knee. The ghost dance business basically fizzled out immediately thereafter. General Miles' combination, which was the combination that the army had used successfully since the 1870s of carrot and stick. He tightens the cordon around the reservations, rounds up any stragglers. But he says, if you go back to the reservation, if you abandon this ghost dance nonsense, we will be lenient. We will give you food. We will even give you gifts. We will give you perks and things.
多米尼克，难道没有进一步的选择，他们可以进入演艺圈吗？是的，当然。当然，他们可以进入演艺圈。是的，当然。当然他们可以进入演艺圈。迈尔斯逮捕了27名鬼舞者，其中23人选择加入布法罗·比尔的狂野西部表演。作为这样做的一种补偿，他们的刑期被减免了。我的意思是，
And Dominic, isn't there also a further option that they can go into show business? Yeah, of course. Of course, they can go into show business. Yeah, of course. Of course they can go into show business. Miles had 27 ghost dancers arrested and 23 of them chose to sign up with Buffalo Bill's Wild West show. And they had their sentences commuted as recompense for doing that. And I mean this,
我觉得这是一个绝对令人难以置信的故事。其中包括踢熊和短牛，他们是那两个去进行那种大朝圣以将鬼舞的消息带给拉科塔人的家伙。他们说，好吧，一切都结束了，达斯蒂。一切都结束了。一切都消失了。我们将加入布法罗·比尔。他们被允许出狱加入布法罗·比尔的表演，
I find this just an absolutely mind-boggling story. These included Kicking Bear and Short Bull who were the two guys who had gone on that kind of big pilgrimage to bring the word of the ghost dance to the Lakota. They said, fine, it's all done, Dusty. It's all over. It's all gone. We'll sign up with Buffalo Bill. They were allowed out of jail to join Buffalo Bill's show
并去欧洲巡回演出。于是他们去了欧洲。我们有伦敦报纸上的广告。布法罗·比尔说，我将展出在伤膝河英雄战斗中俘获的囚犯。伤膝河之战，而不是大屠杀。是的，没错。50名参与伤膝河战斗的最坏的印第安人。这些人甚至根本不在那里。我的意思是，这就是令人难以置信的事情。有一个舞台表演，你在伦敦或巴黎或其他地方看到它，他们会重演这场战斗，这些人会扮演反派，被击败的反派。所以他们上场，会有嘘声和嘶嘶声。
and go on a tour of Europe. So off they go to Europe. We have the adverts from the London newspapers. Buffalo Bill said, I will be exhibiting the prisoners taken in the heroic battle at Wounded Knee. The battle of Wounded Knee, not the massacre. Yeah, exactly. 50 of the worst Indians engaged in the Wounded Knee fight. These guys weren't even there. I mean, that's the incredible thing. There's a stage show, you'd see it in London or in Paris or whatever, and they would re-enact the battle and these guys would play the villains, the defeated villains. So they come on and there are boos and hisses.
正是如此。有一个可怕的细节。我不记得我在哪本书里读到过这个，但它令人难忘。巡演的最后一站是在苏格兰的格拉斯哥，
Exactly. And there's a terrible detail. I can't remember which book I read this in, but it's unforgettable. The very last date of the tour was in Glasgow in Scotland. and there's a terrible detail. I can't remember which book I read this in, but it's unforgettable. The very last date of the tour was in Glasgow in Scotland and when the show was over and they were leaving, Kicking Bear insisted on staying on the stage. He didn't leave the stage with the other performers and he started speaking to the audience. What he was actually doing, people think,
当演出结束他们离开时，踢熊坚持留在舞台上。他没有和其他表演者一起离开舞台，他开始对观众说话。人们认为他实际上在做的是，
was telling them what had really happened, putting right what had unfolded in the last two hours. But he was speaking in Lakota. No one could understand him. Nobody knew what he meant and nobody knows what he said. Isn't that sad? Yeah. A couple of years later, 1893, Frederick Jackson Turner, a very famous American historian, wrote an article called The Significance of the Frontier in American History, one of the most famous things ever written about American history. And he said, the US has been living this extraordinary historic movement. This has been a specific moment in world history where the conquest of the West, what the Mediterranean was to the Greeks, the frontier has been to the United States and directly into Europe, more indirectly. And now he says four centuries from the discovery of America, I suppose discovery of America isn't a phrase you'd use now, discovery of America at the end of a hundred years of life
告诉他们真正发生了什么，纠正过去两个小时里发生的事情。但他用拉科塔语说话。没有人能听懂他。没有人知道他的意思，也没有人知道他说了什么。这不是很悲伤吗？是的。几年后，1893年，弗雷德里克·杰克逊·特纳，一位非常著名的美国历史学家，写了一篇名为《边疆在美国历史中的意义》的文章，这是关于美国历史写得最著名的东西之一。他说，美国一直在经历这种非凡的历史运动。这是一个世界历史上的特定时刻，西部的征服，就像地中海对希腊人一样，边疆对美国人来说也是如此，更间接地对欧洲也是如此。现在他说，从发现美洲四百年后，我想“发现美洲”不是你现在会用的词，在宪法下生活一百年后，边疆消失了，随着它的消失，美国历史的第一阶段也结束了。所以边疆消失了。每一个美洲原住民都被围捕，基本上被关押在保留地。白人定居点已经遍布整个大平原，所有海岸之间的州。大多数人认为这是终点。这是美洲原住民的终点。他们会凋零，要么灭绝，
under the constitution, the frontier has gone and with its going has closed the first period of American history. So the frontier is gone. Every last Native American has been rounded up and basically incarcerated on a reservation. White settlement has spread across all the Great Plains, all the intervening states between the two coasts. And most people think this is the end. This is the end of Native Americans. They will wither and they will either die out
要么变得……被同化。完全同化，这实际上并没有发生。我的意思是，这是他们弄错的事情之一，因为在美国仍然有近400万人，他们在人口普查中认定自己属于某个特定的部落。还有大约600万人是混血儿。所以他们可能是半个切罗基人或半个拉科塔人等等。所以这给了你总共近1000万人，大约占总数的3%。而且正如我们所知，他们往往是迄今为止最贫穷的，最不可能有工作，最不可能健康长寿的人。他们生活在被失业、酗酒、阿片类药物成瘾等各种问题困扰的地方，几十年来一直如此。但是多米尼克，仅仅从历史上看，这个故事的历史被理解的方式。我的意思是，有一种说法，我认为不仅仅是一种说法，我认为这显然是真的，今天美洲原住民对所发生事情的理解，其显著性比当时将伤膝河大屠杀呈现为一场光荣胜利时要大得多。在某种程度上，美洲原住民的视角已经获胜了。是的，我认为你在史学方面是对的。所以自从迪·布朗的《魂归伤膝河》以来。但我甚至怀疑在那之前，有人给我发了一首歌，我没见过，是约翰尼·卡什唱的《卡斯特》。现在我要告诉你，巴斯特，我不是卡斯特的粉丝，他在1964年写的，它是关于美洲原住民的曲目专辑的一部分。
or they will become... Be assimilated. totally assimilated, which actually doesn't happen. I mean, that's one of the things that they got wrong because there are still almost 4 million people in the United States who identify in the census as belonging to one specific tribe. And there are about 6 million people who are mixed. So they might be half Cherokee or half Lakota or whatever. So that gives you a total of almost 10 million people, which is about 3% of the total. And as we all know, they tend to be by far the poorest, the least likely to have jobs, the least likely to live to a ripe old age in good health. And they live in places blighted by unemployment, alcoholism, opioid addiction, all of these kinds of things, and have done for decades. But Dominic, just on the history, the way the history of this story is understood. I mean, there is a case for saying, I think more than a case, I think it's clearly true, that today the Native American understanding of what happened has a salience that is inconceivably greater than it was at the time when the Massacre of
他当时声称有切罗基血统。事实上，他根本没有。我的意思是，他完全是英国爱尔兰血统。所以他和巴菲·圣玛丽一起唱了这首歌，她是一位非常有名的活动家，声称有加拿大原住民血统，但同样，根本没有。而且我认为，确实有一些定居者的后裔现在想要认同那些被流离失所的人。汤姆，我能感觉到你正准备解释这是他们基督教的结果，他们同情弱者和受害者，因为美德在于受苦。我认为这绝对是他们基督教的结果，他们同情弱者和受害者，因为美德在于受苦。我认为这绝对是其中的一部分。
Wounded Knee was being presented as a glorious victory. That in a way, the Native American perspective has triumphed. Yeah, I think you're right in terms of the historiography. So since Dee Brown, Bury My Heart at Wounded Knee. But I wonder even before that, somebody sent me, I hadn't seen it, a song by Johnny Cash called Custer. Now I will tell you, Buster, that I ain't a fan of Custer, which he wrote in, I think, 1964, and it was part of an album of tracks about Native Americans.
我认为，我的意思是，毫无疑问，拉科塔人并没有庆祝那些被他们夺走土地的人。他们没有说，哦，可怜的乌鸦，他们是吗？不，不，他们永远不会那样做，会吗？不，他们不热衷于那个。基本上被纪念的不是那些割掉睾丸之类的东西。不。
And he was kind of claiming to have Cherokee ancestry. And in fact, he didn't at all. I mean, he was completely kind of British Irish ancestry. So he sang it with Buffy St. Marie, very famous kind of activist claiming indigenous Canadian ancestry, but again, wasn't at all. And there is a sense, I think, that there are certainly descendants of the settlers who now want to identify with the people who were displaced. Tom, I can feel you gearing up to explain that this is a consequence of their Christianity, that they empathize with the underdog and with the victim, because in suffering lies virtue. I think that is absolutely a consequence of their Christianity, that they empathise with the underdog and with the victim, because in suffering lies virtue. I think that is absolutely a part of it.
不是那个。它是那种残忍感，以及发生在他们身上的恐怖感。但我猜这也是我们开头读到的那一点，即使是最种族灭绝的白人也承认拉科塔人的英雄品质，并为此哀悼。我想是这样。所以我认为有一种基督教的反射，对受害者的认同。是的。受害者最终战胜了胜利者的感觉。
I think that, I mean, there's no question that the Lakota did not celebrate the people whose lands they'd taken. They were not saying, oh, the poor crow, were they? No, no, they'd never have done that, would they? No, they were not into that. And basically what is being commemorated is not the whole cutting off testicles stuff. No.
我的意思是，在道德上，但显然不是在土地占有或财富方面。但我认为这也是对我们在整个系列中一直在谈论的荷马史诗品质的一种回应。完全是这样。这是荷马史诗与工业文明的共存，使得这个故事如此非凡。我认为这是绝对正确的。我在华盛顿的美洲印第安人博物馆里印象非常深刻。他们有一个非常有力的展览，基本上是美国文化和历史中对美洲原住民的描绘。它基本上是无休止的红皮肤和分数，以及拿着战斧砍掉头颅的人，以及他们被用来销售一切的方式，你知道，从黄油，是的，华盛顿红皮肤美式橄榄球队，他们在2020年被重新命名，最终变成了华盛顿指挥官队，这种感觉不仅是失败的事实，而且是之后堆积在他们身上的侮辱。是的，但实际上华盛顿红皮肤队是一个非常有趣的例子，因为他们在乔治·弗洛伊德谋杀案后放弃了这个名字，基本上是为了回应“黑人的命也是命”。而且我认为仍然有一种因素，当然，你现在永远不会拍一部西部片了。
It's not that. It is the sense of the cruelty and the whole cutting off testicles stuff. It's not that. It is the sense of the cruelty and the horror of what happened to them. But I guess also it's a bit what the reading that we began with, that even the most genocidal white people do recognise the heroic quality of the Lakota and kind of mourn it. I think so. So I think there is a kind of Christian reflex, the identification with the victim. Yeah. The sense that the victim ultimately triumphs over the victor.
并非如此。而是那种残酷感，以及关于割掉睾丸之类的种种事情。并非如此。而是那种残酷感，以及发生在他们身上的恐怖事件。但我想，这也有一点像我们开头读到的那样，即使是最种族灭绝的白人，也承认拉科塔人的英雄品质，并为此感到哀悼。我想是这样的。所以我认为这是一种基督教式的反射，即对受害者的认同。是的。那种受害者最终战胜了征服者的感觉。
I mean, morally, but obviously not in terms of possession of land or anything or wealth. But I think there is also a response to the Homeric quality that we've been talking about throughout the series. Totally there is. It's the coexistence of the Homeric with industrial civilization that makes this story so remarkable. I think that's absolutely true. I was really struck in the Museum of the American Indian in Washington. They have a very powerful little exhibition, which is basically depictions of Native Americans throughout American culture and history. And it's just basically endless redskins and scores and people with tomahawks hacking off heads and stuff and the way in which they've
我的意思是，在道德上是这样，但显然在土地所有权或财富方面并非如此。但我认为，这也是对我们整个系列中一直在讨论的荷马史诗品质的一种回应。完全是这样。正是荷马史诗与工业文明的共存，使得这个故事如此引人注目。我认为这绝对是真的。在华盛顿的美国印第安人博物馆，我深受震撼。他们有一个非常有力的微型展览，基本上是美国文化和历史上对美洲原住民的描绘。基本上就是无休止的“红皮肤”、野蛮人，以及拿着战斧砍下人头之类的人，还有他们被使用的方式
been used to sell everything you know from butter yeah the washington redskins american football team who were renamed in 2020 and ended up becoming the washington commanders the sense that it's not just the fact of the defeat but it's also the indignities piled upon them afterwards yeah but actually the washington redskins is a really interesting example because they dropped the name after the George Floyd murder, basically in response to Black Lives Matter. And I think there is still an element of, sure, you're never going to make a Western now
被用来推销各种东西，你知道，从黄油到，是的，华盛顿红皮队，那支在2020年更名为华盛顿指挥官队的美式橄榄球队。这种感觉不仅在于战败的事实，还在于之后强加给他们的屈辱。是的，但实际上华盛顿红皮队是一个非常有趣的例子，因为他们在乔治·弗洛伊德被谋杀后放弃了这个名字，基本上是为了响应“黑人的命也是命”运动。而且我认为仍然存在一种因素，当然，你现在永远不会再拍一部西部片了
in which the Plains Indians are the baddies. I mean, that's inconceivable. Well, you say that. I mean, I think the film is being made of blood meridian in which everyone is the baddie. Yeah, that's fine. You could do that, I think, but I don't think you could do a John Wayne type film, right? No, no, no. But I do think the issue, frankly, is not seen as glamorous, as morally virtuous, or as salient as the issue, for example, of slavery. So that project that we
其中平原印第安人是坏人。我的意思是，这简直不可思议。好吧，你这么说。我的意思是，我认为正在拍摄的《血色子午线》电影里每个人都是坏人。是的，那没问题。我想你可以那样做，但我不认为你能拍出约翰·韦恩那种类型的电影，对吧？不，不，不。但我确实认为，坦率地说，这个问题不像奴隶制问题那样被视为迷人、道德高尚或突出。所以那个项目，我们
talked about when we did the American Revolution episodes, the 1619 project run by the New York Times, which was an attempt to basically recalibrate all American history on very woke lines and make it all about slavery and all about the sufferings of African Americans. They do that with African Americans, but they wouldn't do it. It wouldn't be as sexy if they did it with Native Americans. There's a sense, I always think, that this is an under-discussed,
在我们做美国革命那一集时谈到过，即《纽约时报》发起的“1619项目”，它试图基本上以非常“觉醒”的路线重新校准所有美国历史，并使其完全围绕奴隶制和非裔美国人的苦难展开。他们对非裔美国人这样做，但他们不会对美洲原住民这样做。如果他们对美洲原住民这样做，就不会那么吸引人了。我总觉得有一种感觉，这是一个被讨论不足的，
a massively under-discussed area of American history. But it must kind of shadow Thanksgiving. Of course it doesn't. How many of those films have you seen where Will Ferrell is travelling and he has to make it back to Thanksgiving and, you know, there's no... No, I know know but I think it is to a degree now I think every
一个在美国历史上被严重低估的领域。但这一定会在某种程度上给感恩节蒙上阴影。当然不会。你看过多少部威尔·法瑞尔旅行并必须赶回过感恩节的电影，你知道，没有……不，我知道，但我认为在某种程度上，现在我认为每
time Thanksgiving comes around people say well who gives us the food I think the only people that say that are academics on social media yeah maybe but I think against that there is a sense of the kind of the power I mean it's almost like a kind of a desire to rewild the great plains yeah of course you know see the buffalo back see the wolf back but also see the cultures that existed there come back but the tragedy of that right is that those cultures are now trapped in aspic and people want them to be trapped in aspic so i talked in a previous episode about how i've been on holiday to the american southwest and been to monument valley which is actually run by Navajo. And there, basically, the communities make their money by playing themselves.
当感恩节到来时，人们会说，好吧，是谁给了我们食物？我想只有社交媒体上的学者才会这么说。是的，也许吧，但我认为与之相对的是一种力量感，我的意思是，这几乎就像一种想要让大平原恢复原始状态的渴望。是的，当然，你知道，看到水牛回来，看到狼回来，也看到曾经存在于那里的文化回来。但悲剧在于，这些文化现在被困在琥珀中，人们希望它们被困在琥珀中。所以我之前在某一集里谈到过，我曾去美国西南部度假，去了纪念碑谷，那里实际上是由纳瓦霍人管理的。在那里，社区基本上靠扮演自己来赚钱。
Yeah, by cosplaying. Yeah, by playing their own ancestors. And I find it, I mean, I wasn't that unsettled by it because I still went, but it was on my mind the whole time. I mean, this is Buffalo Bill. It's basically Buffalo Bill's show. It is Buffalo Bill. It absolutely is Buffalo Bill. It's woke Buffalo Bill. I completely agree. But the thing that I think is striking about this, and another reason why it is so powerful and yet so tragic, is that far from embodying, we've said this before, but a kind of timeless culture, it's a brief moment in the sun that the Lakota are predatory expansionists in exactly the
是的，通过角色扮演。是的，通过扮演他们自己的祖先。我发现，我的意思是，我并没有因此感到不安，因为我还是去了，但这整个过程一直在我脑海里。我的意思是，这就是布法罗·比尔。这基本上就是布法罗·比尔的表演。这绝对是布法罗·比尔。这是“觉醒”版的布法罗·比尔。我完全同意。但我认为关于这一点令人震惊的是，以及它之所以如此强大却又如此悲剧的另一个原因是，它远非体现了我们之前所说的某种永恒的文化，它只是在阳光下短暂的一刻，拉科塔人是掠夺性的扩张主义者，正如
way that the settlers are. It's just that the settlers come in such overwhelming numbers that ultimately the Lakota have no chance of withstanding them. But they do have this fleeting moment and the power of their culture is such that it has triumphed over the victors. I think people do feel its power. They do feel a kind of regret victors. I think people do feel its power. They do feel a kind of regret for it. I think they do. I think it's going too far to say it's triumphed over the victors though, Tom. I mean, what's the balance of sympathy been with in this series?
定居者那样。只是定居者的数量如此庞大，以至于拉科塔人最终没有机会抵挡他们。但他们确实拥有这短暂的时刻，而他们文化的力量足以战胜胜利者。我认为人们确实感受到了它的力量。他们确实对它感到一种遗憾。我想他们确实感受到了。汤姆，我认为说它战胜了胜利者有点过头了。我的意思是，在这个系列中，同情的平衡点在哪里？
I would say with the Lakota, not with the 7th Cavalry. Yeah. I mean, I kind of respect the courage of members of the 7th Cavalry who rode with Custer. I mean, I really do. But I would say the balance of sympathy is with those who end up losing. Sure. But I think that's not the victory you'd want to win, right? I'm not saying it isn't. Of course. I mean, they've lost everything. But I don't think
我会说是拉科塔人，而不是第7骑兵团。是的。我的意思是，我确实尊重那些与卡斯特一起骑行的第7骑兵团成员的勇气。我的意思是，我真的尊重。但我会说，同情的平衡点在于那些最终失败的人。当然。但我认为那不是你想赢得的胜利，对吧？我不是说不是。当然。我的意思是，他们失去了一切。
that the narrative that says the brave boys of the 7th Cavalry behaved with perfect discipline, which is what Sherman is writing about Custer's performance at Washita and then, you know, the performance of the 7th Cavalry at Wounded Knee. I don't think that that is the perspective anymore. No, it isn't. You're right. I think within the Academy, indeed in popular history and in popular renditions of this story.
那种认为第7骑兵团的勇敢小伙子们表现得纪律严明的叙事，也就是谢尔曼在写卡斯特在沃希托的表现，然后是，你知道，第7骑兵团在伤膝河的表现，我不认为那还是现在的观点。不，不是。你是对的。我认为在学术界，确实在通俗历史和这个故事的流行演绎中也是如此。
But I think popular culture as well. Popular culture. Yeah, of course. In Hollywood and everything. Of course. I mean, I agree that is small compensation, but it's better than nothing. I guess the other interesting question is how could it have been different? So I think it's actually really hard to imagine how it could have played out differently. I was thinking about the contrast with the other story we did, which is a bit like this, which is Mexico.
但我认为流行文化也是如此。流行文化。是的，当然。在好莱坞和所有地方。当然。我的意思是，我同意这只是微小的补偿，但总比没有好。我想另一个有趣的问题是，事情本可以有何不同？所以我认为真的很难想象事情会以不同的方式发展。我一直在思考与我们做的另一个故事的对比，那个故事有点像这个，那就是墨西哥。
The difference in Mexico is that the indigenous people are sedentary. They have cities. They're not blown away by the arrival of european civilization because they're already there and actually what happens is there's quite quickly a fusion between european arrivals and the existing peoples of kind of mexico mesoamerica here that wasn't possible because they're not sedentary they don't have cities they don't have towns they're moving and their entire way of life is predicated actually on an ecosystem that would be destroyed by the arrival of mass migration from across the sea but i do think the blaze of their destruction does kind of linger in a way that the destruction of other peoples in america
墨西哥的不同之处在于原住民是定居的。他们有城市。他们不会因为欧洲文明的到来而被摧毁，因为他们已经在那里了。实际上发生的是，欧洲移民与墨西哥、中美洲现有的民族之间很快就发生了融合。在这里，这不可能，因为他们不是定居的，他们没有城市，他们没有城镇，他们是在移动的，他们的整个生活方式实际上是建立在一个会被来自海外的大规模移民到来所破坏的生态系统之上的。但我确实认为，他们毁灭的光芒确实以一种其他美国民族的毁灭所没有的方式挥之不去。
hasn't of course the image of the the kota warrior with the war paint and the feathers particularly yeah is the image of the Native American in the world. Yeah, it is. To that extent, I think that is tribute to the power of this story and the tragedy of it. It is. Tom, you're very keen to find that silver lining, aren't you? Well, I mean, it's such a downer. Anyway, listen, this has been an epic sweep, so we should come to a close.
当然，涂着战纹、戴着羽毛的拉科塔战士形象，尤其是，是的，这就是世界上美洲原住民的形象。是的，确实如此。在某种程度上，我认为这是对这个故事的力量和悲剧性的致敬。确实是。汤姆，你非常热衷于寻找一线希望，不是吗？好吧，我的意思是，这太令人沮丧了。总之，听着，这是一个史诗般的跨度，所以我们应该结束了。
And it's been a long series, our longest yet. Yeah, to give people a sense. For this this uniquely, we've recorded this episode at 7.30 in the morning because we ran out of time. We had literally no hours to record because we'd recorded so many episodes. We keep putting in the schedule, finish this series.
这是一个很长的系列，是我们迄今为止最长的一个。是的，让人们有个概念。为了这个独特的系列，我们是在早上7点半录制这一集的，因为我们时间不够了。我们录制了太多的剧集，以至于我们真的没有时间录制了。我们一直在时间表中安排，完成这个系列。
Yeah. Oh, we've got three more we need to do. Anyway, thank you all, those of you who have accompanied us this far to the bitter end. Yeah. Thank you very much for listening. And we'll be back soon with something I suspect a little shorter. Shorter and very different.
是的。哦，我们还有三集需要做。总之，谢谢大家，那些陪伴我们走到最后的人。是的。非常感谢你们的收听。我们很快会带着一些我怀疑会短一点的内容回来。更短且非常不同。
Bye-bye. Bye-bye. I'm Marina Hyde. And I'm Richard Osman. And together we host The Rest Is Entertainment. It's your weekly fix of entertainment news, reviews, splash of showbiz gossip. And on our Q&A, we pull back the curtain on entertainment and we tell you how it all works. We have just launched our Members Club.
再见。再见。我是玛丽娜·海德。我是理查德·奥斯曼。我们共同主持《剩下的就是娱乐》。这是你每周的娱乐新闻、评论和一点点演艺圈八卦的来源。在我们的问答环节中，我们揭开了娱乐业的幕布，告诉你它是如何运作的。我们刚刚推出了我们的会员俱乐部。
If you want ad-free listening, bonus episodes and early access to live tickets, head to therestisentertainment.com. That's therestisentertainment.com. There aren't comments yet for this episode. Click on any sentence in the transcript to leave a comment.
如果你想要无广告收听、额外剧集和提前获得现场门票，请前往 therestisentertainment.com。那是 therestisentertainment.com。这一集还没有评论。点击转录中的任何句子来发表评论。